Ich bin äußerst pünktlich heute, sehe ich gerade, fast exakt 9 Uhr, aber ich bin heute
ziemlich Bettgemodus.
Ja, habe ich schon, habe ich schon gerade.
Jojo27, 20 Monate Subscription, das ist äußerst, äußerst nice, äußerst Bock und äußerst
5Head.
Leute, ich muss euch was erzählen.
Ich hatte letzte Woche auf der neuen Arbeit den ersten richtigen 5Head-Moment, wo ich
was gelöst habe, was schon Monate gibt an Fehlern und bis jetzt noch keiner draufgekommen
ist.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das regelmäßig jetzt alle Woche mal vorkommt sowas, aber
ab und zu und dann freue ich mich immer, wenn irgendwie sowas sich ergibt, ja.
Und zwar, weil es erzähle ich euch, erzähle ich euch gleich, wenn ein bisschen mehr Leute
da sind, weil vielleicht hat der eine oder andere auch das Problem, könnte ich mir durchaus
vorstellen, das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen verbreiteter.
Vielleicht bringen wir euch das ja was.
Falls ihr euch schon immer gefragt habt, warum ist das so langsam, dann erkläre ich euch
das jetzt.
Ich muss gerade mal was schauen auf dem zweiten Monitor.
Sack.
Immer früher, wieso?
Ich bin eigentlich immer um 9 online, spätestens, wahrscheinlich bin ich, also meistens bin
ich sogar ein paar Minuten davor online.
Keck wait.
Okay, gut.
Ja, ich musste gerade noch mal was nachgucken hier.
Alles klar, was Werbung wird immer cringiger, muss mir den SOM mehr Deal zuge- oh ja, Leute
ich hatte gestern jetzt, ohne Scheiß, also Twitch übertreibt es total, ich wollte gestern
einen Stream gucken und da gab es tatsächlich 9, ich wiederhole, 9 Werbeblöcke oder Werbespots,
9 Stück und ich hab das so nebenbei laufen gehabt und hab mir gedacht, das ist aber irgendwann
und dann steht da oben dann, 5 von 9 Werbespots wären jetzt durch und dann hab ich instant
einfach den Tab zugemacht und ich mir gedacht hab, ne, also jetzt irgendwann 5 von 9, 9
Werbespots, das ist doch nicht mehr normal.
Okay, das können natürlich die Streamer beeinflussen, wenn sie auf Werbung klicken
oder man kann ja irgendwie sagen, ich mach jetzt Pause mal irgendwie 10 Minuten, aber
ganz im Ernst, ne ne, also so ein Scheiß.
Es ist auch blöd, dass man es nicht ausschaltet, also ich würd's ausschalten, ich verdiene
mit der Werbung eh so gut wie nix, dass ich das lohnen würde, aber Twitch verdient daran,
also insofern wollen die wahrscheinlich nicht, dass man das deaktiviert, aber das ist total
übertrieben und nachdem es ja ein ziemlich enges Wettrennen mittlerweile geworden ist
aus Twitch und Adblockern, dass Adblocker, sag mal, mindestens 50% der Zeit, so wenn
man es über so ein Jahr sieht, nicht in der Lage sind, Twitch-Ads zu blocken, außer mit
Custom-Adblockern und Regeln und allem, wird's auch immer nerviger, wegen mehr im Sommer
als nicht.
Warte, ich muss mal ein bisschen irgendwas einschalten, was haben wir denn hier noch
so?
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, bisschen, bisschen wupp, wupp, wupp, okay, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp,
wupp.
Ne, die müssen sich auch nicht wundern und ich hab, ihr werdet mich jetzt wahrscheinlich
für bescheuert halten, warum ich das überhaupt mache, aber ich war letztens auf gutefrage.de
über die Seite, ist ja jeder schon mal gestolpern, hat sich gefragt, was die Daseinsberechtigung
überhaupt ist von dieser Seite, also ich, wie gesagt, das ist so eine Art Stack-Overflow
für alle Themen im deutschsprachigen Bereich, nur, dass die Antworten halt absolut bescheuert
sind oftmals, ja.
So, zumindest, ich hab, ich hab gegoogelt und zwar, wisst ihr, was ich gegoogelt hab?
Ich wollte für meine Mutter auf dem Tablet einrichten, dass die sich mit der neuen, weiß
ich gar nicht, welche, ING-DiBa war das, glaub ich, App verbinden kann, so und die App ist
so dermaßen beschissen gemacht, dass du nicht weißt, welche deiner Codes, Pins, Passwörter,
Username, Kontonummer, Deponummer und was auch immer es da nicht alles gibt, beim Login eingeben
sollst.
So, und dann hab ich gegoogelt danach, was der Unterschied ist zwischen den unterschiedlichen
Nummern und das Erste, was rausgekommen ist, ist eine Frage, also ist gutefrage.de oder
gutefrage.net oder so ist es ja, glaub ich, als, als Antwort, so nach dem Motto, die,
die wissen, die wissen, was Sache ist, ja.
Das Problem ist nur, die wussten es halt auch nicht und die Seite, warum ich jetzt überhaupt
darauf komme, die Seite war komplett, die konntest du nicht sehen, die war komplett
zu mit Werbung auf dem Tablet, es war links ein Werbebanner und rechts war in der Mitte
über die Seite noch ein Werbebanner, es war quasi so ein, so ein T-Werbebanner hier so
und dann so ein Werbebanner, du konntest die Seite einfach gar nicht angucken.
Dann hab ich's auch gleich wieder zu gemacht, wo ich mir so gedacht hab, jetzt ist ja auch
mal gut, ich mein, will man wirklich so viel Werbung haben, dass die Leute die Seite nicht
mehr sehen, weil dann gucken sie sich nicht die Werbung und nicht die Seite an und machen
direkt wieder zu.
Ja, die sind alle, also du kannst das Internet mittlerweile, es wird, es ist fast wieder
so schlimm, wie sagen wir mal 90er, 2000 rum, wo alles auch voll mit Werbebannern war und
teilweise noch mit Werbebannern, die irgendwelche Sachen ausführen konnten in deinem Browser
auf der Webseite, ganz wirres Zeug, wie das damals eingebunden wurde und die Browser waren
da damals auch noch bei weitem nicht so secure wie heute.
Es ist fast wieder so schlimm zu der Zeit, wo die ganzen Werbeblocke überhaupt erstmal
ursprünglich aufgekommen sind, du konntest ja damals das Internet auch gar nicht benutzen
ohne Werbeblocker und es ist quasi konstant so geblieben, ein bisschen runtergegangen
vielleicht die letzten Jahre, aber insgesamt ist das Internet wieder fast unbenutzbar ohne
Werbeblocker.
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die gehen mir wirklich auf den Keks im Internet, das
sind, also online sagen wir mal, nicht nur im Internet, aber generell online, gehen mir
die auf den Keks.
Also da ist die Werbung, also diese ultra aufdringliche, wir erkennen von der Seite nix Werbung, ist
da nur eins davon.
Ja, der Zwang dazu bei jedem Scheiß sich irgendwie einen Account anlegen zu müssen
ist auf jeden Fall auch einer.
Cookie-Meldung, DSGVO-Meldung ist das nächste.
Gibt noch ein paar Sachen.
Wenn ich ja länger drüber nachdenken würde, fallen mir bestimmt 20 Dinge ein, die mir echt
auf den Keks gehen.
So in der heutigen Internet-Zeit.
Ja, aber das bringt ja bei vielen Contents, achso ja und eine Sache, die mir auch extrem
noch auf den Keks geht, ist immer noch und wir reden vom Jahr 2023, dass Filme, Serien
und sagen wir mal generell Medien und Content immer noch Region-Lock, nee Region-Lock ist
das falsche Wort, immer noch Region-Based irgendwie released werden.
Das fuckt mich so ab.
Es gibt Dinge, die will man sich angucken und stellt dann fest, oh der Release war ja
nur Amerika, wir müssen noch zwei Monate warten und dann gehst du auf irgendeine Seite
und willst dir das Ganze angucken und dann kommt dann, ach nee, sie befinden sich außerhalb
von Amerika, sie können das jetzt noch nicht gucken, muss halt ein VPN oder sowas.
Warum?
Was soll dieser ganze Müll immer?
Man kann es doch eh relativ einfach umgehen.
Was soll der ganze Müll überhaupt?
Warum ist das noch ein Ding und warum gibt es und warum gibt es in Deutschland immer
noch Wort-Releases ohne Original-Tonspur?
Also was ich ganz gerne mache ist zum Beispiel, wenn das irgendwelche Sachen sind, wo sie,
wenn das irgendwas aus England ist und die teilweise so abgedrehte, da gibt es ja ganz
viele Dialekte, ja, nur wenn da irgendwelche Schotten ankommen und verstehst ja kaum, wenn
die Englisch reden.
Und dann mache ich manchmal ganz gerne halt Original-Tonspur, aber deutsche Untertitel,
weil ich einfach absolut keine Ahnung habe, was sie verstehen, äh was sie sagen und
ich sie nicht verstehe und ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass das sogar manchen Nativespeakern
so geht, dass sie die Kerle nicht verstehen.
Ja und es ist halt blöd, wenn das nicht geht.
Also man, du kannst halt oftmals in Deutsch gucken, aber ich gucke es halt am liebsten
Original-Tonspur und manchmal mit deutschen Untertiteln.
Das ist für mich so eine gute Kombination, wenn da ganz zu viele abgedrehte Dialekte
drin sind.
Aber tja, geht halt oftmals nicht, weil Wortseiten zacken.
Ja, übrigens, wisst ihr, was auch so eine schlimme Sache ist oder eine Sache, die mir
auch auf den Keks geht im Internet, ja hier, wir haben ein ganz tolles Angebot, bestell
dir das doch jetzt und du willst es dir angucken und denkst dir, ach okay, ist doch eigentlich
gar nicht so übel.
Und du suchst also den Preis und du findest den Preis nicht und denkst dir so, ah gut,
klickst du das mal an, als willst du es bestellen und bevor du den Preis siehst, sollst du den
Account anlegen.
Mache ich nie.
Das ist der Moment, wo mein bestellt, mein eventuell stattfinden könnender Bestellprozess
abrupt interrupted wird, weil ich mir keinen Account einstelle, nur um zu sehen, was ich
theoretisch bezahlen müsste.
Die sollen das halt ordentlich hinschreiben, was das kosten würde und dann überlege ich
mir auch, ob ich das haben will, wenn ich das haben will und unbedingt einen Account
brauche, vielleicht mache ich mir dann einen Account, aber umgedreht ist einfach ätzend.
Ja, ich kenne auch eine Wortzeichnung, die nicht sagt, aber die ist ja leider nicht monetarisiert,
sollte man uns vielleicht auch mal überlegen.
Direkt 5 Werbebanner, nicht mal unbedingt, es gibt viele seriöse Shops, die das so machen,
aber ich werde das dann nicht bestellen.
Ja, oder wenn du quasi schon den Versand und den Bestellprozess nahezu abschließen musst,
dass du den Versand siehst oder das teilweise wir, aber wenn man sich erstmal anmelden muss,
um überhaupt den Preis zu sehen und ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Shops so nach
dem Motto, only for businesses, wo du dich erstmal mit Umsatzsteuer-ID und allem möglichen
Zeug registrierst, das meine ich gar nicht, ganz normale Shops.
Letztes Mal, Beispiel zum Beispiel, ja, letztes Mal habe ich irgendwie so eine Werbung bekommen,
das war so sinngemäß, so, je verschönern sie ihre Wohnung, mit regelmäßigen Blumen
Lieferungen.
Leute, ich hätte nicht wirklich vor, das abzuschließen, aber ich wollte mir das mal
angucken.
Ich habe mir gedacht, okay, ich meine, mal gucken, was ihr anzubieten habt, ja, habe
ich draufgeklickt und da stand dann, ja, kaufen sie sich das jetzt und kriegen sie regelmäßig
passend für das Ambiente und bla, kriegen sie irgendwie passend Blumen und so, also
okay, dann zeigt doch mal, was das kosten würde.
Ich wollte einfach nur mal wissen, was kostet das.
Habe ich draufgeklickt und dann erzählen sie, oh, sie sparen jetzt 30%, wenn sie das
jetzt abschließen, na, das ist ganz toll und bei der ersten Bestellung gibt es eine
kostenlose Vase dazu und bla, bla, bla, bla und ich denke mir allzu, ich scrolle die Seite
durch, ich scrolle die Seite durch und denke mir so, ja, und was kostet denn jetzt, einmal
im Monat oder einmal im Jahr oder einmal irgendwas, was, was kostet denn jetzt und ich scrolle
durch, es steht nirgends wo, es steht nirgends wo, was das kostet, dachte ich mir, okay,
weißt du was, ich tue einfach mal so, als will ich es bestellen, habe gesagt, ja, okay,
ich will das hier einmal im Monat, so und so viel, so, keine Vase, next, next und dann
dachte ich mir, es zeigt mir den Preis, aber nein, dann sollte ich erstmal einen Account
anlegen und ich meine, ich hatte eh schon nicht vor, mir das zu kaufen, aber spätestens
an der Stelle war einfach harter Cut in meinem Bestellprozess und ich habe direkt den Tab
geclosed und werde den Shop wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder benutzen.
Was soll der Scheiß, warum könnt ihr mir nicht den fucking Preis anzeigen, ohne dass
ich mich registrieren muss, vielleicht ist der Preis so krass, dass es eh keiner kaufen
würde, aber das ist trotzdem nicht die beste Idee, das hinter einem Account zwang, warum
ist der Preis hinter einem Account zwang, das ist einfach bescheuert, ich würde gar
nicht mal so sagen, dass es, ja doch, also, wenn du das in der Summe anguckst, prozentual
vielleicht, aber es gibt auch viel, viel mehr Zeug mittlerweile, ja, du hast ja neben so
Sachen, die es früher gar nicht gab, früher hattest du ja so Sachen wie Twitch, YouTube
und fällt schwer zu sagen, TikTok und sowas, hattest du alles nicht, aber selbst wenn man
so die klassischen Filme, Serien und sowas Produktion nimmt, es gibt ja mittlerweile
so viele, ja wie nennt man es, Studios und Sachen, die Zeug produzieren oder so viele
Unternehmen, die Sachen in Auftrag geben, jeder Streaming, jeder Hersteller hat eine
eigene Streamingseite, jede Streamingseite ist der Meinung, wir brauchen ein paar exklusive
Sachen und da ist auch viel Shit dabei, aber doch durchaus das eine oder andere gut, also
es gibt sehr viel und ich muss auch sagen, es ist sehr viel, sehr viel Müll, aber es
gibt auch die ein oder anderen guten Sachen, was mich ja persönlich immer so ein bisschen
nervt ist, gerade wenn du dir irgendwie Serien anguckst und du fandest die erste Staffel
ganz gut und die nächste ist halt so richtig mies, wo du so denkst, okay, ihr habt euch
überhaupt keine Gedanken gemacht beim Erstellen der ersten Staffel, so nach dem Motto, wie
könnte es weitergehen, das war überhaupt nicht im Scope, da gibt es einige Dinge oder
auch wo ich so im Laufe der Serie denke, also ich glaube, ich habe mehr Serien aufgehört
zu gucken in der Mitte, als ich sie zu Ende geguckt habe, wenn man davon ausgeht, also
soweit sie guckbar waren, nicht wirklich zu Ende, viele werden ja auch eingestellt, aber
gehen wir mal davon aus, keine Ahnung, ich gucke irgendwas, es gibt schon drei Staffeln
und es ist öfters passiert, dass ich irgendwie so Ende zweiter Staffel dann gedacht habe,
so langsam wird es aber dumm, als dass ich dann noch das letzte geguckt hätte oder so,
also ich gucke das meiste gar nicht fertig, deswegen mag ich auch Serien, die so nach
einer Staffel halbwegs abgeschlossen sind, ja, also das ist ein ganz, ganz, irgendwie
wenn es so einen ordentlichen Schlussstrich gibt, aber gut, ohne Cliffhanger gucken die
Leute dann halt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht die nächste Season, ja, das ist im Enterprise,
hast du recht, das ist im Enterprise, aber die wissen warum, die wissen, die wissen warum,
weil die Software aussieht wie von 1998 wahrscheinlich, das habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt, ich weiß
gar nicht, ob ich das, ob ich das jemals mache, Witcher ist auch so ein Beispiel, ich fand
die erste Season auch nur, naja, aber ich hatte dann beispielsweise gar keinen Bock
mehr weiterzugucken danach, naja, Shopify, ist, war Shopify nicht von irgendeinem Deutschen,
der das entwickelt hat, also natürlich nicht in Deutschland, sondern irgendwo in den USA,
aber ich glaube das war irgendein deutscher Auswanderer oder so, der die, der Shopify
entwickelt hat, ja, unterm Strich muss man aber sagen, ist das tatsächlich eine gute
Entwicklung gewesen, weil es gibt ja nicht nur Shopify, es gibt ja noch mehr solcher,
wie nennt man das, so Sales, Sales, Customize, quasi Wordpress für Shops im Endeffekt, eigentlich
eine ganz gute Entwicklung, weil früher war es wirklich nicht einfach, wenn jetzt irgendwie
so eine, ich kann euch mal eine Story erzählen, ich habe früher mal, das ist schon wirklich
lange her, das müsste, keine Ahnung, 2000 oder so, wie alt war ich denn, 2016, ja, das
kommt irgendwo noch ein bisschen älter, 99, 2000 drum so müsste das gewesen sein, da
habe ich ein bisschen Webshops gebastelt, allerdings nur ein bisschen das Styling und
so drumherum, das war damals eine Software, die nannte sich SmartStore, glaube ich, wenn
ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, so und das war ein Shop Generator, du hast quasi
deine Produkte reingeschrieben und dann hast du generieren gedrückt, nee, das meine ich
gar nicht, Classic, ist das noch, ist das nicht SmartStore, ach, ich weiß nicht mal
wie der Krempel hieß, zumindest hast du da deine Sachen eingetragen und dann hast du
auf generieren gedrückt und das hat dir ein Verzeichnis rausgeworfen, mit HTML, CSS
und du hattest dann quasi einen statischen Shop, den konntest du hochladen auf irgendein
Hoster oder einen halbwegs statischen Shop, ja, das war damals eigentlich eine coole Sache,
die war in ihrer Zeit voraus, aus Aesthetics, Side Generation und so kam 20 Jahre später
wieder als Riesentrend, war aber eine gute Sache, weil du konntest es auf jeder Seite
hosten, auf jedem Webspace hosten, du hast keine MySQL Datenbank oder irgendeine Datenbank
gebraucht und, wobei bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob du die gebraucht hast, es war eine
ganz coole Sache und ich hab damals ein bisschen Styling und CSS, ein bisschen JavaScript
Zeug gemacht für so Shopseiten und was damals halt echt ein Riesenakt war, für kleinere
Shops sowas zu erstellen, ich kann das, genau, jetzt weiß ich auch was ich eigentlich erzählen
wollte, ich hab damals für irgendeine Esoterik, so mit Heilsteinen und sowas, ich zeige euch
jetzt nicht, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es die Seite noch gibt, gucken, ob es das
noch gibt, ne, gibt's nicht mehr, so und das war so ein Esoterik Shop, für die ich ein
bisschen Design oder beziehungsweise ein bisschen Setup von dem Shop gemacht hab, die haben Anhänger
verkauft und Heilsteine und so komischen Kram und wie gesagt, da war ich so 15, 16 irgendwie
in dem Dreh und das hab ich dann, keine Ahnung, 50 Euro oder so ab und zu gekriegt, ich meine,
das fand ich damals halt schon extrem, extrem pork, ansonsten hab ich eh nur 24, 7 MMO Kreisel
Grind gemacht, so zumindest, ich weiß noch, wie schwierig für die das damals gewesen ist,
einen Shop online zu stellen und damals waren gesetzliche Regelungen wahrscheinlich noch
einfacher zu durchschauen und für solche, gerade für solche kleinen Dinger sind natürlich so
WordPress Style Shops, also so quasi WordPress nur für Shops eigentlich ganz gut, da kannst,
da musst du dich nicht um Bezahlung kümmern, du musst dich nicht um das, um das Setup großartig
kümmern, du musst eigentlich nur dein Zeug reinschreiben, ein bisschen customisieren gut
ist, so für kleine Shops ist das glaube ich wirklich extrem nice, das ist so Sachen wie
Shopify und wie heißt der andere Krempel, dass es das gibt, naja, wie gesagt, ab und zu mal 50
Euro oder so war das, das war nicht, war nicht, dass ich da reich geworden bin mit, aber es war
für damals so mit, so als 15, 16 war das schon sehr nice, immer mal ein bisschen, bisschen money
zu kriegen, ja, denke ich auch, ich hatte jetzt persönlich, also irgendwie, ich hab da noch nicht
selbst drüber verkauft oder was gemacht, aber alles, was ich bisher gesehen habe, wie heißt
die, wie heißt diese andere, versus, Shopware, genau, das meinte ich, gibt's auch noch, da gibt's,
gibt's eine, aber Shopware meinte ich, das ist teilweise, Squarespace, Squarespace, das kenne
ich, das sind die, die immer die T-Shirts verkaufen, Wix, eh besser Webhoster vom Namen her, die gibt's
ja auch schon lange und, und mittlerweile haben sie, glaube ich, diese Namen auch, gerade im
deutschsprachigen Umfeld machen sie sich ja da auch selbst lustig drüber, moin Max und hast du
die Stop, hast du gefunden, wie man Stop Words macht, ja, jetzt sind ja genug Leute, jetzt kann
ich euch mal was erzählen und zwar, ich hatte letzte Woche auf der Arbeit, ihr müsst keine
Channel-Punkte raushauen, ich habe gerade schon was getrunken, echt nicht, okay, aber weißt du,
was wir machen können, wir können das, wir können das einfach, wir können das einfach oder was
heißt wir, das hört sich ja so an, als könnte ich da was machen, klein-seitig einfach erstmal rausfiltern,
wenn das jemand ins Suchfeld eingibt oder sowas, irgendwas, irgendwas Billiges, das reicht ja erst
mal schon, so, ich wollte euch irgendwas erzählen, genau und zwar, ich hatte letzte Woche auf der
Arbeit, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass einer, dass der eine oder andere von euch genau diesen Fehler
schon hat, deswegen erzähle ich euch das mal, ich hatte letzte Woche auf der Arbeit zu meinem ersten
richtigen Five-Header-Moment und zwar ging es um ein Problem, was es schon Monate gibt und es
hat bisher noch keiner den Fehler rausgefunden, das ist ja normal in einem größeren Umfeld, dass es
da immer Probleme gibt und auch viele Probleme Monate, Jahre bestehen bleiben, ne, habe ich
noch nie benutzt, habe ich noch nie, ich habe noch nie wix.com benutzt, ich weiß nicht, gibt es das
eigentlich auch mit de mittlerweile, ne, das ist irgendwas anderes, irgendwas anderes, was damit
nichts zu tun hat, null, ihr sollt mich einfach mal sponsoren, dann mache ich auch in irgendeiner,
in irgendeinem Stream mache ich dann auch eine Wix, eine Wix-Webseite, aber nur, aber nur, wenn ich,
aber nur, wenn ich gesponsert werde, weil ich sehe den Sinn von solchen Webseitenbildern für
mich, für meine Anwendungszwecke nicht, zumindest kann ich euch erzählen, was ich euch erzählen
wollte, also, erster Five-Head-Moment und zwar, wir hatten ein Problem auf der Arbeit und zwar,
wenn man kubernetes-Cluster administriert, dann verwendet man ja meistens das Tool kubectl,
wo manche Leute, wo ich immer, wo ich immer so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Pains champen muss,
wenn manche Leute nicht kubectl sagen oder kube-control, sondern kubectl, ich weiß immer
noch nicht, wo das herkommt, das machen erstaunlich viele, ich weiß nicht, ob es absichtlich ist oder,
ja, keine Ahnung, doch, das machen ziemlich viele, kube, so kann man sogar, guck mal,
sogar Google, sogar Google auto-vervollständigt das, gibt sogar GitHub-Projekte, ja, da sprechen
viele Leute so aus, zumindest, das ist überhaupt nicht, das ist überhaupt nicht das,
von was es gehen soll, also und zwar, wir hatten das Problem, dass immer, wenn du kubectl ausgeführt
hast, dass es unregelmäßig hing, das hing immer unregelmäßig in ein paar Minuten, weiß nicht,
ob jemand von euch schon mal das Problem hatte, in Google Cloud, Google Cloud, GKE-Cluster,
kubectl ausgeführt in unregelmäßigen Abständen, zumindest dachten wir das,
in unregelmäßigen Abständen hing das immer für ein paar Minuten, ja, also, falls ihr auch das
Problem habt, erzähle ich euch jetzt, woran das liegt und wir haben sogar intern, das war noch,
bevor ich angefangen habe und ich habe schon zweieinhalb Monate, bin ich jetzt schon da, gab
es da schon, schon ein paar Monate alt, sogar ein Google-Support-Ticket von uns, natürlich,
selbstverständlich war Google nicht in der Lage bisher, das Ganze zu lösen, so Support-Anfragen
sind eigentlich immer absolut maximal useless, hat jemand von euch schon mal eine wirkliche,
gute Antwort bekommen bei einer Support-Anfrage an Oracle, Google, Microsoft, IBM oder Konsorten?
Bisher, also, ich kenne keine wirkliche Support-Sachen, die wirklich geholfen haben.
Vom Azure-Support, okay, was habt ihr gefragt? Also, vom Azure-Support habe ich bisher auch
nichts Gutes mitbekommen, die haben immer den, die Standard-Taktik, die haben die Frage,
die man gestellt hat, nochmal anderweitig formuliert, wiederholt, damit sie ihre
Reaktionszeiten einhalten und haben gefragt, wenn das das Problem gelöst hat, dann bitte das Ticket
schließen. Microsoft hat tatsächlich ihren Change richtig, okay, aber, okay, das war ja auch irgendwie
so ein Bug-Report, was wahrscheinlich nicht nur euch betroffen hat, aber so Anfragen wie,
warum hängen die Tools? Also, ich habe selten, okay, sagen wir mal, streichen wir mal das nie,
aber ich habe selten bisher zufriedenstellende Antworten von den großen Supports bekommen,
gerade Oracle ist da ultra wenig hilfreich immer, aber Microsoft und Google auch. Zumindest,
es gab ein Ticket bei Google und es gab sogar ein Ticket bei Red Hat, weil man hat vermutet,
also, wie gesagt, Fehlerbild ist, man führt kubectl aus gegen den Google-GKE-Cluster und
es hängt ab und zu mal für ein paar Minuten. Es gibt ein Ticket bei Red Hat, es gibt ein Ticket bei
Google und beide hatten keine Ahnung, warum gibt es dort Tickets? Naja, weil es halt auf Red Hat
zum größten Teil zumindest ausgeführt wird und weil es halt Google-Kubernetes-Cluster sind,
also insofern ist ja logisch, warum man dort Tickets aufmacht. Beide Seiten keine Ahnung,
so und dann wurde ganz viel Zeug probiert und rumgebastelt und irgendwie hat nix gebracht,
so und letzte Woche Freitag ging mir das so auf den Sack, dass ich mir gedacht habe,
ey, weißt du was, das musst du dir jetzt mal richtig angucken, das kann es doch nicht sein,
also auf geht's. Ich kann euch jetzt mal grob erzählen, wie man sowas analysiert,
wobei es auch ein bisschen Zufall war zwischendurch, dass ich das Richtige gefunden habe,
aber ein bisschen Glück gehört immer dabei. Okay, das Erste ist, ich habe es ausgeführt und
habe mal die Zeit gemessen, wie lange es hängt und Leute, ratet mal, wie lange es hängt. Es ist
eine sehr spezifische Zeit, die man kennt, wenn man Linux-Tools verwendet und es hängt immer
gleich lang, 69 Seconds, du bist gar nicht so weit weg von 5 Sekunden, ne, ne, ne, ne, Minuten,
Minuten hängt es. Ne, ne, es hält länger. Also ich kann es euch sagen, es hängt immer 2 Minuten,
ziemlich genau 2 Minuten. So, das ist schon mal verdächtig. Das ist schon mal sehr verdächtig,
wenn was immer exakt 2 Minuten hängt. Nicht mal 3x, 4x, 1x, sondern immer 2x. Das heißt,
da ist irgendwas nicht kaputt in dem Sinn, sondern irgendwas reproduzierbar. So, das Nächste ist,
ich habe mal probiert, wann es hängt. Also, was habe ich gemacht? Ich kann euch übrigens mal
Six-Head-Befehl zeigen, wenn ihr das noch nicht kennt, wie man sowas schön testen kann. Ich mache
mal kurz meinen Linux-VR-Mann. Hat sich schon gelohnt, ja. Nein, das war nichts mit Systemd.
Also, was ich dann gemacht habe, ist, ich habe eine Schleife angeschmissen. While True, so Echo
1, 2, 3, dann Schleife. So, und in die Schleife habe ich folgendes reingeschrieben. Timeout,
Minus, Minus, Signal, ich glaube Kill, nach 10 Sekunden und dann glaube ich, ich mache jetzt
mal sinngemäß ein Sleep. Sleep 5 ergibt ja nicht wirklich Sinn, aber Kill 2. Achso, okay. So,
und das geht mit Sleep überhaupt nicht, oder habe ich es jetzt falsch geschrieben? Kill? Tja,
weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr. Quit? Was ist Kill minus 9? Was macht Terminate? Term? Okay,
ich glaube, ich habe das jetzt überhaupt richtig, richtig geschrieben. Na gut, ich mache ja keine
Ausgabe, deswegen klappt das nicht. Okay, so kann man das machen, zum Beispiel. Ich hoffe,
das stimmt jetzt, was ich gebaut habe. Ja, genau. Also, was das macht, ist, das startet, Timeout
startet ein anderes Programm und nach 2 Minuten, wenn sich das Programm, nach 2 Sekunden, wenn sich
das Programm innerhalb von 2 Sekunden nicht beendet hat, dann killt es das Ganze. Also,
wenn sich Sleep 5 Sekunden, nach 2 Sekunden, nicht beendet hat, wird es gekillt. Also,
es wurde immer gekillt. Also, habe ich das Ding mal in der Schleife laufen lassen und habe davor
einfach ein Date gemacht und habe mir das angeguckt, so wie oft das auftritt. Ja, normalerweise war das
immer so nach dem Motto, ja, wir sind fertig, okay, okay, okay, dann habe ich es gekillt. So,
und im Endeffekt hat sich herausgestellt, es ist alle 15 Minuten für 2 Minuten und das ist doch
schon sehr verdächtig. Sachen, die alle 15 Minuten hängen und dann exakt für 2 Minuten. Das riecht
doch wirklich nach Netzwerktimeouts oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder es riecht nach Caching und in
Verbindung mit Netzwerktimeouts. Also, habe ich mich mal auf die Suche gemacht, woran könnte
das da liegen, was macht CubeCTL denn, was Netzwerktimeouts verursachen könnte bzw. an
welcher Stelle könnte das Ganze hängen. So, und dann bin ich draufgekommen mit, also, man kann
das ja mit unterschiedlichsten, ich habe hier kein kubernetes-Zeug laufen, aber man kann das ja
mit unterschiedlichsten Verbose-Settings ausführen. Ja, dann sieht man hier, was der macht. Und
zwischenzeitlich sieht man auch, okay, CubeCTL benutzt die Curl-Library tatsächlich, um seine
Requests zu machen. Und wisst ihr, was der Default-Timeout von Curl ist? Mal kurz gucken,
ich glaube, wir werden jetzt nicht sehen, ob 60 Sekunden stimmt. 120 Sekunden ist nämlich eher das,
was ich meine. Ja, genau, das ist das, was ich meine. Der Curl-Timeout defaultet zu 2 Minuten.
Und jetzt erkennt man schon irgendwie den Zusammenhang, okay, das Ding hängt für 2
Minuten. Der Default-Curl-Timeout ist 2 Minuten. Das scheint ja irgendwas miteinander zu tun zu
haben. So, und was ich dann als nächstes gemacht habe, ist, ich habe einen Proxy gesetzt. Einen
Proxy, den es nicht gibt, also sowas in der Richtung Export, HTTP, Proxy, gleich 127001 oder
sowas. So, und wenn man jetzt CubeCTL ausführt, dann sieht man, okay, wir können nirgends,
okay, ich dachte eigentlich, das benutzt er automatisch, aber okay, macht er nicht. Zumindest
kriegt man, hätte ich gedacht, zumindest hat mein CubeCTL automatisch Proxy-Settings benutzt. Was
auch immer, zumindest, wenn man ein Proxy gesetzt hat, den es nicht gibt, dann hat man gesehen,
dass CubeCTL ausspuckt, a, wir haben ein Problem bei der Verbindung zu Google. Und im Endeffekt
hat sich herausgestellt, dass, und jetzt erkläre ich euch, woran es gelegen hat, also CubeCTL
selbst macht einen Curl auf eine externe Google-Seite, nämlich gstatic-feature.xml. Fragt mich
nicht, wie die richtige, gstatic-feature.xml. Also es gibt irgendeine Public-Seite von Google
und dort wird irgendeine Feature-Json, ist es, glaube ich, wird eine Feature-Json abgerufen,
findet man so über Google gar nicht. Wahrscheinlich passiert das, damit die Google-Tools checken
können, ob es Updates gibt oder ob irgendwelche Teile von der Google Cloud disabled sind oder sowas.
So, und warum macht CubeCTL das? Weil unser CubeCTL das Google-Authentifizierungs-Plugin
verwendet für die GKE-Cluster. Also sprich, eigentlich ist die Reihenfolge so, wir führen
CubeCTL aus, CubeCTL führt das Google-Kubernetes-Authentifizierungs-Plugin aus, das Google-Kubernetes-Authentifizierungs-Plugin
führt G-Cloud aus, mit G-Cloud-Config-Helper, G-Cloud-Config-Helper hieß das, glaube ich,
ja, G-Cloud-Config-Helper, ja, und dann mit irgendwelchen Magic-Parametern. Und wenn man
das versucht auszuführen mit, mit, was ist das? Ne, Config-Helper gibt's nicht. Wie ist das denn?
Ist das einfach Config-Helper? Ach, was auch immer, ich krieg das aus dem Kopf nicht mehr
genau hin. Dann hat es ausgespuckt, ey, wir wollen eine Verbindung machen zu G-Static.com
bla bla bla feature.json.feature.xml und an der stelle hing es für 120 sekunden bis
der curl-timeout erreicht war. sobald ich den externen proxy gesetzt habe
waren die timeouts instant weg. so und dann war es eine kombination aus
wir müssen einmal warten 120 sekunden bis der timeout durch ist dann läuft
kubectl weiter weil das auth-plugin abkackt und diese requests die
sind einfach gecached für 15 sekunden in in hier punkt kube irgendwas hier
genau gut gut dass ich das hier auch habe hier sind die dinger dann drin
gecached und das timeout allerdings nach irgendwie 15 oder 20 minuten und
da geht das ganze wieder von vorne los das heißt es hat nichts damit zu tun wie
oft man das benutzt und es hat nichts damit zu tun dass es irgendwie random
wäre das problem ist dass das ding versucht ins internet zu kommen zu einer
public google seite von einer vm die nicht public ins internet darf das
heißt wer sich wundert warum sein kubectl mit google hängt in irgendeinem
privaten privaten cluster netz bei google was nicht im internet was ich
nicht ins internet darf das liegt daran das google auth plugin möchte zu einer
public internet seite connecten und kann nicht und dann hängt es zwei minuten und
das alle 15 minuten für zwei minuten fehlerbehebung ist relativ easy man
setzt den proxy dass es ins internet darf oder aber und das ist das was ich
nächste woche mal ausprobieren muss oder aber das problem tritt da tritt tritt
auf weil unsere firewalls traffic droppen anstatt ihn zu rejekten gehe ich auch
also gehe ich von aus dass das mit da rein spielt weil normalerweise wenn du
versuchst eine verbindung zu machen wo du nicht hin darfst und die firewall
sagt reject dann kriegst du eine fehlermeldung oder kann das tool
weitermachen wenn du einfach nur packages droppst dann muss das wirklich
120 sekunden da bleiben und warten bis das bis das durch ist also falls ihr
mal irgendwie probleme habt dass euer kubectl hängt in umgebungen die nicht
ins internet dürfen gerade in verbindung mit google cloud und im google cloud
plugin dann liegt es höchstwahrscheinlich daran es ist reproduzierbar sobald es
diese verbindung machen kann geht es instant das ist das also entweder macht
man auf jedem server eine ip tables regel die das die das rejektet anstatt
es droppt oder man macht eine host eintrag auf g static wobei das noch mehr
auswirkungen hat ja solche solche dinger aber da muss man auch erst mal drauf
kommen nein ist es nicht ist es nicht die cloud
github ist es nicht also das authentifizierung plugin ist nicht und
ich glaube ach ist das hier ich glaube ich glaube nicht dass g cloud ist das
g cloud cli ist das das ist python gedöhnt das weiß ich ist das open
source source g cloud source code
hier ist es jetzt ist es jetzt open source oder nicht
da ist das wahrscheinlich mit drinne moment das ist doch die falsche cloud
stk github wo ist das denn gibt es das irgendwo anscheinend nicht oder an
official also ist okay also es gibt es gibt nix wo man pull request pull
request machen kann dagegen das aber schon ein bisschen blöd oder sonst
hätte sonst sonst hätten wir uns mal nützlich machen können und und
tatsächlich mal ein pull request einreichen können nicht nicht dass das
eine chance hättest bei google was zu kommitten weil da musste irgendwie
tausend agreements sein und sowas source code mirror of g cloud mirror von wo
wahrscheinlich von hier okay das ist irgendwie das gibt es nicht
das tolle antworten die nichts die nichts damit zu tun hat
anscheinend anscheinend nicht warum eigentlich google das musst du die
leute fragen die das entschieden haben keine ahnung ich persönlich hätte es
auch netter gefunden wir hätten weiter wir würden er verwenden weil mit er
kenne ich mich besser aus wobei es mittlerweile mit google geht ich mache
schon zweieinhalb monate nur google cloud aber es ist halt so entschieden
worden irgendwann mal dass die hauptsächlich google cloud verwenden
insofern ja jetzt ist jetzt nicht dass ich da irgendwas großartig dran machen
kann nee nee das das administrations tool
probiert das wenn du wenn du auf einem kleinen rechner
cube ztl aufrufst dann lädt es das google cloud authentifizierung
plugin das musst du benutzen dass du dich gegen dass du cube ztl gegen google
kubernetes cluster benutzt verwenden kannst und das wiederum ruft g cloud auf
das g cloud cli tool das da mit konfig helper und irgendwelchen parametern und
das google cloud tool cli tool macht die verbindung zu einem public public google
service das ist schwierig zu verpacken in einem video kommt ein bisschen random
aber könntest du vielleicht mal verraten wie du diese formen oben
moment das da oder oder das da du meinst hier den krempel hier oben in der leiste
also zum beispiel auch sowas wie cpu auslastung er meint die cpu auslastung
das hier den cpu auslastungskraft ach das hier die leiste ach ja das kann ich dir
zeigen das ist nicht selbst gemacht das ist ein tool was sich bumblebee status
nennt da gibt es aber zig sachen die statusleisten generieren für i3 und das
verwende ich mit dem plugin alert shell indicator memory disk load cpu und
so und das hier ist die cpu auslastung das ist fertig das gibt es auf github
das ist das tool mit dem ich das mache übrigens wie gesagt das ist nicht das
einzige da gibt es da gibt es tausende solcher tools die die statusleisten für
i3 generieren wenn du dir meine konfig angucken willst kannst du hier bei mir
in github gucken unter dort konfig i3 da ist meine i3 konfig drin der ist ja nicht
so groß in 100 und 100 zeilen so und ach so das wird bei die eine das eine
plugin wird bei dir nicht gehen nämlich das ist es alert das ist das was wir
selbst gebaut haben alert diesen diesen countdown den haben wir
haben wir selbst gebaut hier den gibt es nicht public zumindest das kannst du dir
hier angucken und die das war es mehr mehr mehr konfig hat das nicht das ist
alles was dann konfig brauchst du kannst hier die themes einstellen und dann
brauchst du noch eine schriftart hier die gut aussieht im endeffekt eine die
dir gefällt so sieht es aus das war es mehr musste nicht machen das klimaanlage
ausschalten kühl hier aber warum sind die packages nicht direkt in den gke
es geht nicht um die gte notes es geht um den kleinen rechner der die admin
tools ausführt das hat nichts mit den gte notes dazu tun weil du bist ja schon
du bist ja noch gar nicht connecte zu deinem gte cluster zu dem zeitpunkt das
geht ja folgendermaßen du führst du führst cube ctl get pods aus ja was jetzt
nicht geht weil naja was jetzt nicht geht weil es läuft halt bei mir lokal
kein kubernetes cluster wenn du wenn du cube ctl in die cube ctl command ausführst
dann muss das ja sich zu irgendeinem kubernetes cluster verbinden den du im
vorfeld konfiguriert hast es gibt plugins wie du einfach cluster
switchen kannst aber du musst du musst den cluster ja konfiguriert haben so
damit du dich gegen den cluster connecten kannst brauchst du irgendeine
authentifizierung und das kannst du entweder mit den offiziellen
integrierten authentifizierung sachen machen oder mit irgendeinem
authentifizierung plugin und in form bei google wird ein
authentifizierung plugin mit mitgeliefert wenn du cube ctl über wenn
du g cloud components oder sowas install ja guck da musst du hier dieses
authentifizierung plugin installieren für cube ctl was dann wiederum ein
request macht zu google zu dem google cloud tool was dann wiederum
authentifizierung request macht für den kubernetes cluster das ist damit damit
cube ctl credentials bekommst um sich verbinden zu können zu deinem gkl
cluster ich weiß warum bei mir mini cube nicht
startet es liegt daran weil docker hängt wenn
man vms resumed oder weil ich oder weil ich ein kernel update gemacht habe ohne
zu rebooten das kann ja auch sein das hängt mir jetzt aber schon erstaunlich
lang was da los wir machen mal kurz ein package update eigentlich oder etwas
getan was gibt es hier noch kein kubernetes im homelab ne ich habe keine
kein 16 node cluster bei mir docker run hello world können wir mal gucken ob
docker noch funktioniert ja ne doch kernel update was bei mir hängt im
hintergrund jetzt macht auch kein update okay da war noch machen wir noch
mal package update was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes hier ja visual studio
code ein paar icon themes wunderbar lassen wir updaten dann machen wir ein
reboot und dann sollte der ganze krempel wieder funktionieren
ich bin ja nicht technotim der daheim drei racks stehen hat mit kubernetes und
virtualisierung sachen wo ich bin wobei ich wie immer noch frage bei dem was mit
dem los ist ja also warum warum man diesen kram überhaupt hat hier den hier
meine ich fünf kubernetes cluster daheim ja ich meine es ist sicherlich
sicherlich nice um zeigt er sein rack irgendwo noch mal genau einfach wenn man
spaß am basteln hat ist das nice aber ich brauche keinen zweiten job daheim
bei mir um mich um eine infrastruktur zu kümmern
irgendwie kann man es auch übertreiben wissen wie ich meine also ich habe ich
habe ich habe es ja früher auch total übertrieben mit technik bei mir daheim
aber mittlerweile denke ich mir ich habe keinen bock mich neben meinem normalen
job noch um meine infrastruktur daheim in halbtag kümmern zu müssen macht er
nicht nur youtube keine ahnung was der macht wenn er nur youtube macht und dass
sein content ist mit dem er geld verdient dann ja verstehe ich es aber
trotzdem so docker ran sollte nicht gehen wir
rebooten mal und dann sollte hoffentlich wieder alles tun
sehen wir gleich sehen wir gleich ich reboot jetzt und dann jetzt kommt mir
die frage magst warum wenn es zu kein display manager warum ich kann einfach
einmal start x eintippen warum soll ich die display manager für
leute white people happy time sonnenaufgang so restore sag docker ran
erst mal checken gibt es neue jet brains updates tools ja rider wurde
geupdated ach nee die eap variante ne die will ich gar nicht haben warum habe
ich warum habe ich überhaupt noch die eap variante installiert ich glaube für
dort ein acht räume an den store weg damit
ok so docker ran funktioniert minikube minikube start gucken ob es jetzt
funktioniert ja jetzt funktioniert alles okay gut ja mein docker war mein
docker war proben deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert was zuckt denn der down
laut so jetzt funktioniert es gibt anscheinend eine neue version die habe
ich noch nicht runtergeladen deswegen dauert das jetzt kurz so und ratzfatz
haben wir gleich lokalen kubernetes cluster den ich gar nicht brauche weil
ich eigentlich gar nichts zeigen will aber ich will wissen ob es jetzt wieder
funktioniert unter artsche bei der welt habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt dass
ich bei meiner bei meinem vorstellungs ok das muss ich muss ich anders muss ich
anders machen es gab vor ein paar wochen bei uns so
eine einführungsveranstaltung und das war so richtig cringe socialize event
ihr wisst ja wie sehr ich sowas mag und da sollte man im vorfeld gab es so ein
ein gemeinsames
ja bort für neue mitarbeiter und da sollte jeder so einen kurzen steckbrief
ausfüllen das war quasi so eine riesen so eine riesen seite im intranet von
jedem von jedem halten mit name und bild und und abteilung dabei und team dabei
und dann sollte man zwei sachen unten drunter unten drunter ausfüllen so für
für diese forscht für diese große einführungsveranstaltung genau da sollte
man raufschreiben so was ist meine superkraft und so so komisches so
komisches zeug und ich habe drauf geschrieben ios arts bei der welt es
waren zwei sachen die man draufschreiben sollte aber das das war schon das ich
habe schon wieder für wieder verdrängt was das zweite war also das eine war
fun fact das eine war fun fact über mich und das andere war meine superkraft so
richtig das können sich nur irgendwelche personal abteilungsleute
ausgedacht haben die im vorfeld irgendwelche was weiß ich rhetorik
kurse gemacht haben oder sowas genau das sollte das sollte man draufschreiben
fun fact und meine superkraft und bei meiner superkraft habe ich hingeschrieben
ios arts hat wahrscheinlich außer mir und vielleicht noch einem anderen
nichts verstanden und fun fact habe ich drauf geschrieben also habe ich mit
meinem ich habe ja zusammen mit einem ehemaligen kollege angefangen jetzt bei
der neuen arbeit wir haben beide das gleiche drauf geschrieben so dass wir
uns schon von früher kennen so ich habe geschrieben ich kenne ihn schon von
früh und ich kenne max schon also total sinnlos ok so wir haben wir haben ein
kubernetes cluster am start gert potts jawohl es funktioniert so und das ist
das was ich euch gerade zeigen es war bei mir auf der arbeit so wenn ich
kube zdl gert potts gemacht habe zum beispiel so jetzt hing das ding einfach
zwei es sah ungefähr so aus wenn ich das ausgeführt habe bei mir auf der
arbeit ja ich habe kube zdl ausgeführt dann hing das zwei minuten und dann und
dann ging es ganz und dann ging es einfach ganz normal weiter und 15
minuten später gab es wieder die probleme ja und wie gesagt man kann dann
man kann dann verbuss mode hier hoch schalten und sieht was dafür sieht was
der für für request macht und alles mögliche und da bin ich halt drauf
gekommen mit mit der zeit also wenn ihr das problem habt dass euer kube zdl hängt
in verbindung mit google cloud habe ich das habe ich gerade ausführlich erzählt
also wenn ihr probleme habt dass euer kube zdl hängt in der gerade gegen
google kubernetes cluster alle 20 15 minuten für immer zwei minuten dann
liegt das daran dass das google kubernetes authentifizierung
plugin beziehungsweise g cloud nicht auf eine static google seite ins internet
kommt g static.com g cloud feature jason oder so will das runterladen und dann
muss es auf auf den timeout warten lösungsmöglichkeiten sind proxy setzen
dass es ins internet kommt oder netzwerktraffic rejecten anstatt zu
droppen hat aber schon hat aber schon eine stunde oder so gedauert bis ich
dahinter gekommen bin es war tatsächlich nicht so easy aber im
nachhinein wie das ist easy alles immer easy
gg eats so sieht es aus was waren wir denn jetzt ja aber nicht nur bei mir sondern es
betrifft ja alle ansonsten lass mal kurz gucken was können wir uns denn was können
wir uns dann schönes anschauen irgendwelche chess player die erneut sind ich weiß nicht
warum youtube immer schach videos vorschlägt ich gucke keine schach videos aber wahrscheinlich
weiß youtube mittlerweile auch dass der chat dass wir so ultra high IQ sind das chat
dass dass das schach videos eigentlich genau unser unser unserem profil entsprechen wann
probieren wir twin text based window in was
das ist doch eh outdated as fuck oder das sieht aus als basiert auf basiert auf n
kurses und n kurses benutzt noch niemand mehr
ja aber was ein schwachsinn alter da kannst du keinen browser aufmachen das ist komplett
unsinnig naja ich weiß nicht so wo gibt es denn das ganze hier okay es wird tatsächlich
aktiv entwickelt ja okay moment twin wie heißt das twin ja auch dated overrated
sie betet gibt es nicht twin get up ja releases tags 0 9 es ist tatsächlich okay das kann man
nicht installieren man muss das man muss es selbst bilden oder da habe ich jetzt keinen
bock drauf install hier billigen installing okay ich klone das repo jetzt und entweder
es kompiliert instant oder wir lassen das und gucken dann videos okay twin also wie
geht das install installing ich war mal ein snapshot davor ich weiß ja nicht was das
ding warum habe ich noch so viele snapshots das verbraucht viel zu viel disk okay make
und okay erst konfigurieren okay es sieht so aus als ist alles da hacker mein modus
aktiviert weiß make let's go chat ich glaube es ist obvious was passiert ich muss dazu
nichts erklären sollte sollte jeder instant verstehen wie fertig das war es jetzt oder
was heißt und jetzt wo ist das wo ist das binary ich weiß nicht wie ich ausführen muss okay das
ist mehr massive high IQ ich will ich will es nicht installen ich will gucken wo die wo die
beiden ja komm ich habe snapshot gemacht macht mega install anne als gut mega install okay
wow twin da ist es okay es ist irgendwie schon ein wenig ein wenig unsinnig ich wüsste jetzt
halt nicht so wirklich was ich damit anfangen soll ja okay gut man muss es glaube ich erst mal
also ich ich wüsste wirklich nicht was ich da warum ich verwenden sollte ist ich habe echt
keinerlei anwendungszweck dafür block jepp clock okay wir beenden das jetzt mal ich habe echt
keine ahnung was ich damit anfangen soll die farben ja die sind ein bisschen kaputt so als
wenn wir erst mal wieder den snapshot restoren bevor ich das installiert habe das ist ein
weiterer grund dafür warum 4ms und snapshots best best ever sind jetzt jetzt kommt natürlich
jemand um die ecke sagt ja aber max zfs snapshots man kann es auch dafür übertreiben ja das dass
das schon irgendwie ich weiß nicht so wirklich warum ich für was und warum ich es verwenden
würde so und jetzt muss ich noch mal meine ganzen alten snapshots löschen weil die unsinnig viel
ramp verbrauchen magst ans trinken erinnert exzellent okay weil rollercoaster tycoon ist
ja weil es in assembler programmiert ist weil das extrem 6 hat ist rollercoaster tycoon
was ist das ja i try to find hidden gems on aliexpress again
hat er denn hier ist es so eine mini wasserpfeife oder sowas und das war das mal sag
jetzt so und jetzt lösche ich mal meine ganzen snapshots weil ich weiß nicht warum ich die
snapshots überhaupt warum ich die überhaupt snapshots habe aber ich glaube nicht dass man
das irgendwie noch braucht und es frisst unsinnig viel guck mal hier wie lahm das schon ist und das
ist auf der ssd die irgendwie 5 terabyte die sekunde oder was auch immer ne 5 gigabyte die
sekunde oder so übertragen kann die flutscht extrem die ssd und das ist lahm als fakt na gut
also was haben wir denn hier zu bieten i try to find hidden gems on aliexpress so werden grafiker
auch mal wieder ein video vom our haben wir schon lange nicht mehr geguckt 30 minuten klein was ist
das die neue arbeitswelt der gen set ok das ist wahrscheinlich wieder übelst cringe je nachdem ob
das eine von boomern erstellte reportage ist oder irgendwie zumindest so ein bisschen was in meinem
alter oder so rip google domains ok fireship ist immer neues smart home video auch ich weiß gar
nicht was gucken wir dann wir gucken jetzt hin jams und aliexpress erstes video kann man ein
bisschen drüber skippen wenn ein paar sachen dabei sind die mich aller wie lange braucht er für die
snapshots war lecke viel zu lag man wir müssen nicht zugucken wie er das macht also ich kann wir
können schon weitermachen aber ich bin immer wieder erstaunt wie lahm teilweise das aufräumen von
snapshots ist auf der anderen seite ist es auch verständlich weil er muss ja den ganzen diff
rausfinden und dann applyen in ein neues image weil soweit ich weiß funktionieren die forever
snapshots ja auf wie nennt sich das copy on right base ach was ich machen snapshot und vom snapshot
zeitpunkt werden quasi nur noch diffs gespeichert wenn du das die wenn die snapshots löscht muss
er quasi neues disk image erzeugen mit den aus den diffs zum snapshot deswegen dauert das ein
bisschen unter btfs geht schneller benutzt vor allem bei workstation btfs als snapshot backend
kannst das also mein unter windows ja schon mal mit btfs gar nicht er ist fertig ok nice und bei
btfs ist ja generell immer die frage ist es btfs better fs butter fs oder was ist es denn eigentlich
oder ist es gar btfs dann lasst uns mal die die hidden gems auf aliexpress angucken ja sie ist
low budget wasserpfeife und no it is not a babe das erste was ich gedacht habe
do you know what this is and no it is not a babe electronics but do not worry i also
had no idea what it is useful for making this video okay keine ahnung was das ist
that is the beauty of shopping on aliexpress because there you can find newer and super
useful stuff ja und und das stimmt schon man kann da wirklich useful stuff finden aber es ist
bei aliexpress auch enorm wirklich enorm viel schrott dabei und teilweise auch wirklich gefährliche
sachen also offensichtliche sachen die gefährlich sind zum beispiel laser die man sich bei aliexpress
kaufen kann du kannst dir bei aliexpress laser kaufen die sind so stark die brennen quasi loch
in die hand so nach dem motto also das ist wirklich heftig was es da gibt und du darfst
es dir wahrscheinlich offiziell darfst du dir es wahrscheinlich gar nicht einführen und bestellen
also ihr wisst was ich meine also darfst du nicht in das land einführen und du darfst es wahrscheinlich
nicht besitzen und benutzen aber realistisch betrachtet wird es wahrscheinlich auch keiner
merken deswegen will ich nicht wissen wie viele leute sich dort irgendwelche komischen sachen
bei aliexpress bestellen die durchaus gefährlich sind so und dann andere sachen die auch schon mal
sehr fragwürdig sind die die bieten zum beispiel auch irgendwelche muttermal entfernung setz und
sowas an das würde ich würde mir doch im leben nicht bei aliexpress ein muttermal entfernung
set kaufen und an mir rum schnippeln und lasern alter wie wie los kannst du eigentlich sein dass
du das machst ja max keimwitz wird wird da an allen ecken beworben ist die leistung eines
lasers gesetzlich geregelt ich weiß es nicht aber ich würde mal vermuten ja dass es da vorgaben
gibt sonst hast du wieder sonst hast du wieder irgendwelche lustigen leute die mit aliexpress
lasern flugzeuge an lasern und sowas gab es ja schon ein paar fälle in den letzten jahren die
haben dann flugzeuge angelasert mit mit viel zu starken aliexpress lasern was übrigens wer das
gedacht verboten ist flugzeuge anzulasern hat das nicht apparent mal gemacht keine ahnung aber ganz
ehrlich es wird zu apparent passen ich weiß nicht ob er das gemacht hat aber passen wird es wirklich
gut kann ich mir gut vorstellen wissen was auch bei aliexpress verkauft wird was bei uns nicht
mehr verkauft werden darf oder ich weiß nicht ob es bei uns nicht mehr verkauft werden darf
oder nur mit auflagen glühbirnen so ganz normale glühbirnen kannst du bei aliexpress noch kaufen
und die werden dann dort oftmals auch gar nicht als glühbirne beworben sondern genau genau die
werden die werden beworben als heizung als heizung die und ungefährliche strahlung im
sichtbaren bereich abgibt keine glühbirne ist das gibt es aliexpress ich gehe davon aus man
kann einfach nach glühbirne suchen glühbirnen nein das sind led sachen das ist fälle retro
edison birne pulle es war simon desue nicht apparent ja das ist auch das okay das schlägt
aber in die gleiche kerbe das ist ja das beiden ohne probleme zugetraut es gibt gutes zeug bei
aliexpress keine frage ich habe auch schon viel bei aliexpress bestellt bei mir hauptsächlich
elektronik teile aber aliexpress ist nicht pauschal schlecht es gibt halt viel schrott
aber man kriegt da so ein bisschen das gefühl ich habe nie planen wie man bei aliexpress
bestellt ja das ist so ein bisschen das problem für viele sieht aliexpress halt ultra nach scam
aus wobei ich noch nie gescannt wurde und der eine wenn wir es mal scammt versuch wurde mir
direkt von aliexpress erstattet also wurde ich auch nicht wurde ich auch nicht gescannt als
gutes bestellen bei aliexpress ist eigentlich relativ einfach zu legst du dir ein konto an
und am ende ich glaube man kann mittlerweile sogar schon per paypal bezahlen das hängt ein
bisschen vom shop ab also aliexpress ist ja eigentlich gar kein shop aliexpress ist ja
eigentlich nur ein großer marketplace das hier sind die eigentlichen stores die da was verkaufen
das heißt wenn du dir irgendwie so einen so einen set microcontroller kaufen willst dann kannst du
hier sagen bla bla bla das ist dieser shop der das verkaufte pünktlichkeitsgarantie und da
musst du gucken was die was die für was die für payment und versandarten und sowas anbieten aber
viele bieten auch paypal an teilweise sogar apple pay wenn es der chat sagt ja also ich habe aliexpress
schon lange benutzt und damals musste man sich noch einen alipay account anlegen und leute ich
sage euch alipay account wäre nichts für aluhut leute gewesen du musstest du musstest in der
seite die rein china chinesen mäßig war musstest du mit einem google translator weil du die seite
sonst nicht verstanden hast muss also muss das alie alie pay über google translate irgendwie
aufmachen da musstest du dich da registrieren und dann musstest du deine kreditkarte bei einem
china chinesen auf einer china chinesen seite die du nicht verstanden hast deine kreditkarte
registrieren und dann konntest du mit aliexpress mit alipay auf aliexpress bezahlen leute ich sag
euch das war wirklich nichts für internet noobs und es war eigentlich war es auch keine blöde
war es auch eine blöde idee wirklich meine kreditkarte dort einzutragen heute hätte ich
wahrscheinlich irgendeine fake kreditkarte generiert also eine die funktioniert aber die
ich direkt wieder sperren lassen kann instant mittlerweile es ist aber nicht schlimm weil
die kreditkarte ich da überlegt hinterlegt habe das schon jahre her die mittlerweile längst
abgelaufen und wo ihr auch aufpassen müsst hier bei diesem bei diesem blödsinn bei aliexpress
wenn er teilweise steht irgendwie 46 cent und sowas leute die ganze dinger die kosten nicht
46 cent das ist das ist immer das ist immer plötzlich also zum beispiel ich zeige ich
zeige euch mal was mal gucken ob ich sowas finde ja manchmal manchmal haben diese sachen wie hier
kostet 46 ok die kosten wahrscheinlich wirklich zu wenig hier kostet 46 cent und sowas ja und
wenn ihr da drauf geht werdet ihr feststellen je nachdem was es ist das ist ja das ist schon
mit rabatt manchmal machen dies auch so die packen vier verschiedene produkte in diese seite rein und
das was du haben willst kostet 8 euro aber die haben dann noch ein usb stick mit da drin und der
usb stick kostet nur 40 cent und dann wird das wird das angezeigt auf der übersicht seite als
40 cent produkt obwohl das eigentlich 9 euro kostet das was du haben willst das ist also
aliexpress ist echt so eine wissenschaft für sich aber die bestellung ist mittlerweile ziemlich
easy es sieht halt es sieht halt ultra nach scam aus irgendwo ja es sind stufenbohrer keine
kegelbohrer da musste ich mich mal belehren lassen gift alles klar ich bezahle es aber es ist ein
gift ich bin das immer ich finde das immer sehr nett von denen dass die mir was schenken wenn
ich das bezahle 95 prozent günstiger zusätzlich noch mal ja ja leute klick das mal an und dann
werdet ihr sehen am ende kostet trotzdem mehr die kosten am ende 9 euro ja die sind die sind
wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich ziemlicher schrott aber ich habe auch so ähnliche für 3d trocke und
so sind die ganz gut ja ja wenn du du siehst du siehst du siehst den preis schon wenn du es in
warenkorb gelegt hast ich kann es nicht richtig in warenkorb legen weil ich nicht angemeldet bin
digitaling store ja aliexpress halt ich kann euch nur empfehlen es mal auszuprobieren ich
meine es ist nicht dass irgendwie was passieren könnte ja wenn du über paypal bestellst und
irgendwie auch nur nur bestellst irgendwie keine ahnung 20 euro oder so was was soll passieren
es kann euch halt schrott geliefert werden aber das war es dann auch kann man ausprobieren also
aliexpress lohnt sich es hat sich jahrelang gerade für elektronik teile gelohnt also wenn
du dir transistoren relays widerstände kondensatoren leiter platten also irgendwelche
breadboards esp microcontroller alle möglichen also wenn du sowieso elektronik krams bestellen
wolltest dann war aliexpress einfach extremly deswegen habe ich auch noch so viel esp 32 hier
im vorrat die werde ich wahrscheinlich nie für irgendwas brauchen können ok gucken wir uns mal
an was hat er für hidden gems bei aliexpress moment da hatten wir aber das deutlich bessere
mit so einem board hatten wir schon das deutlich bessere projekt moment archiv titel da ist es doch
also ich finde das ist der bessere anwendungszweck dafür oder jetzt ist natürlich die große
preisfrage heute weeps in oder weeps also warum sollte ich mich darauf anzeigen lassen wenn man
auch was gescheites darauf anzeigen lassen kann heute meint ihr nicht auch es wäre mal wieder
zeit für esp bastel stream das problem ist nur ich weiß nicht was ich basteln soll ich habe
gerade keinen kein anwendungszweck ja das board von ihm hatten wir hatten eine webcam ich weiß ich
habe schon gesehen close a look at six more products from aliexpress that looked intriguing
in order to tell you whether you should check them out or simply ignore them let's get started
this video is sponsored by keysight world innovates excellent let's start off with this development
board here consisting of a screen camera and most importantly was ist es es ist was ist es denn
was ist es denn hier ein module around the tx 510 ic which is in a face recognition module
that you can all together get for around 54 euro ja geil und was also und was soll ich damit machen
oder hätte ich jetzt spontan überhaupt keinerlei anwendungszweck für according to the name this
board should be capable of capturing an image of my face and then recognizing it's under a
variety of conditions which could be really awesome for certain electronic also die alten
dieser also die die alten hat wer dieser kategorie die konnte es ja übelst leicht austricksen somit
wir halten ein foto von dem typ davor und sowas ich weiß nicht wie gut die neuen davon sind weil
das ist ja auch jetzt an sensoren und so jetzt nix wahnsinnig krasses was da drin sein kann
projects the only problem was the description den bewegungsmelder habe ich noch nicht da habe ich
jetzt auch gar nicht mehr geguckt tell me how to use this thing though the only meaningful
information i got was that it can schöne schöne china chinesen anleitung ach ja ist risk 32 core
ist das nicht dieser china die china cpu nee das was anderes oder bis zu 400 megahertz
okay zackig 1000 faces and that it works in dark environments but thankfully this thing is pretty
self-explanatory meaning after powering it we can use the s1 button to capture face image and
gut richtig interessant ist es doch aber nur mit eigener firmware drauf this system does
its face recognition procedure and yes as you can see my face has been successfully recognized
so die frage ist recognize das auch andere als ihn oder wenn man foto hinhält was er erst lange
für den zappt what the limitations of the sport are and all in all i can say that as long as you
directly face the camera it can pretty much always recognize you no matter if you cover part of your
face where your heads wear glasses or sit in complete darkness thanks to the integrated
infrared leds you cannot even trick the boards with 2d images of the captured face meaning it's
only weak point is that it cannot reckon okay das ist schon mal gut dass die billig dass die
sachen nicht funktionieren is your face at an angle which is acceptable i would say so after the
initial testing i was rather happy with the boards and since it requires 5 volts and a
maximum of 800 milliamps to work so nothing exotic it should be pretty versatile to use
but for that we of course needed to communicate with other microcontrollers and for that the
board comes with a serial communication ports that other makers already successfully used and
they even already integrated the boards into home assistant awesome so yeah all in all i would
recommend it okay das ist in der tat ganz nice wenn man selbst was bauen will mit gesichtserkennung
ein problem was ich dabei wieder sehe ist halt du brauchst ein gehäuse was also du musst ja selbst
ein gehäuse bauen gibt ja gibt ja anscheinend nichts fertiges für und wenn du sowas draußen
hinhängen willst ist es mit dem 3d gedruckten gehäuse wahrscheinlich auch nicht getan muss
sie irgendwie wasserdicht bekommen aber tatsächlich ganz interessantes sport ich hätte jetzt keinen
anwendungszweck so direkt aber es ist auf jeden fall gut dass es so dinger gibt only downside
i see is maybe the rather high price point which i honestly think though is justified
because there's a lot going on on this development board but anyway let's move on to the next
products which is this hot plates that at 50 euro is in my opinion quite cheap i initially got it
because even though my mini mini heizplatte dass das benutzen das benutzen manche leute
um sachen gleichmäßig anzulöten also du legst dann quasi deine deine teile also legst da irgendwie
den controller drauf oder irgendeinen pcb drauf mit bestücks das mit so lötpaste
legst deine legst deine bauteile drauf und dann heizt du es für spot hot plates and
diy one do work perfectly fine when it comes to reflow soldering electronic circuits they
are sadly limited in size and thus i quickly pushed them to their limits but as you can see
this new hot plates can house both of my old ones onto it and in numbers that means a heating area
of 10 by 10 centimeter which should be enough for the majority of my pcbs it heats up to a
maximum of 350 degrees celsius with an okay accuracy and after taking it apart i can say
that its overall build quality is pretty good pretty much the only problem it comes with is
that it's surface does not really heat up evenly and thus comes with a hotspot which is a problem
my old hot plates do not come with but even with the hotspots i had no problem so far using the
products and thus i would definitely recommend it because i think the price performance ratio
is incredible
next we got a case here in which we can find the i would say pen from the beginning of the video
that is actually a rosin dispenser
i would seriously have no idea what i'm doing with it
cool mini cooling fan what cool mini cooling fan usb charging soldering fume for phone repair
okay fume are vapors? soldering vapors? soldering vapors? what kind of thing? soldering vapors?
hey max i have a phone interview on tuesday for training in physics i would say that is extremely
nice nice
with the given you speak it
we have to push its button furiously in order to eventually power it on
and then by holding the button we can see that the coil at the top heats up quite a bit
next we need the four small additional packages
aka truffle that come with the pen this stuff is basically a hardened rosin flux i think
that you can usually use with your solder so that
it sticks better to your component leads
but in our case we want to fill the stuff into the dispenser
close it up and heat it up in order to create the smoke that we can then literally pour over
our electronic circuits as you can see this creates an ash-like layer onto the components
that quickly melts away as soon as heat is introduced
so the idea is that if you have a faulty circuit with lots of components and want to find the
component that is defect and thus produces the most heat you can use this technique to do just
that which i think is awesome and i honestly never heard about this before
so far i've been using my thermal camera to find hot spots but that is not as accurate
and also quite expensive which is why this rosin dispenser definitely gets a recommendation from
my sites and the only negative aspect i fear of it is that its coil might not last that long
but then again it is replaceable okay yeah good replaceable
next we come to a trend i see more and more which are such normal looking usb cables
whose other side is me yeah
this is also something that sounds cool in theory but in practice i didn't like it
magnetic and thus can be used with different connectors in my case only with usb-c though
i got my cables for around three euro each so super cheap and yes i get why they are so popular
but i don't think it will work out
the first run didn't go so well
but definitely check out their website
in advance
so that you can get some points
with things that are relevant to them
you probably already have it
check out what they do
maybe you can also
drop some knowledge
oliver thanks for the sub
and thanks to the
subscriptions
nice
IQ-Punkte wieder massiv gestiegen
im chat
popular
because they are not as much in the way
if you want to use your phone while charging
but as you might know
due to one of my previous videos
i love it when my usb cables
waste the least amount of power
while charging
and this magnetic connection here
gave me nightmares concerning that
meaning i had to test it out
so first off
a normal charging test
real fritheo
thanks for the sub
you don't have to google buzzwords
i would check out their website
and check it out in advance
so that you can
get some points
test with both cables
during which the purple cable
pulled off a current flow
of 2.7 amps
aka fast charging
while the red one only did
2.2 amps
so not fast charging
even though they claimed it could do that
next i built up
my usual usb cable test setup
in which i pushed
more and more current through
is that an old zahlmann
cooler?
do you still know the parts?
that looks like the cooler
you put on amd atlon xp
yes
oops wrong button
i think so
that's it
100 pro
look at that
that's a thing
that was back then
a high eq pog fan
that was the only fan
i ever had from zahlmann
i didn't know before
that they make fans
and after that
they didn't make fans
thanks for the sub
wow
clickbuff
uri
the only thing
i noticed
from school
in that direction
uri
oli
oh
nicht gesehen. Ich habe ja auch so Dinger schon verwendet. Ich fand sie einfach nicht praktisch
genug. Moving on to something way more amazing though. Also insofern. These bug boost converters
built around the TPS6302OIC that you can get for around 3€ a piece. Das ist ein ganz normaler
Spannungswandler oder? Ja. Hm. Da kann man ja auch noch ein paar rumfliegen. In allen
möglichen Größen. Das ist. Ist das einer der immer das gleiche rausgibt oder ist das
einer mit so einem einstellbaren Output? Weil ich sehe jetzt da nichts zum drehen. Ja step
up down ergibt wenig Sinn ja. Achso. Da kann man das abgreifen was man haben will. Also
das ist immer. 5 und 3.3 Volt ja. Was Microcontroller angeht. Ja.
Das ist super wenn du nur ein oder 2 Batterien hast die du benutzen möchtest um deine Elektronikprojekte
zu verbinden. Aber zu diesem Punkt könntest du sagen das ist nichts besonderes. Es gibt
viele andere Voltage Converter die das tun. Also warum sollten wir uns um dieses
bestimmte Beispiel kümmern. Nun wenn wir die Inputstrahlung dieses Generik-Converters anschauen
mit nur einer Batterie. Aber bevor ich mir die volle Rekommendation gegeben habe, musste ich natürlich
die restlichen elektrischen Eigenschaften testen. Und hier muss ich sagen, dass die erklärte Max
Output Strom von 3 Ampere nur bei einem Input Voltage von 4 Volt erreichbar war und alles
darunter resultierte in viel weniger Output Strom. Aber das war ehrlich gesagt das größte Problem,
weil die Lautausgaben gut aussahen und nach ein paar Effizienzkalifikationen kann ich sagen,
dass diese auch gut aussahen. Und so wie das, kommen wir zum letzten Produkt,
welches ein weiteres Entwicklungsbord ist, aber diesmal mit einem Mikrofon und einem
Spiegel. Oh yeah, das ist bestimmt Schrott. Ah, obviously, alles klar. Leute, jetzt wissen wir
Bescheid, oder? USB. Das ist auch das Einzige, was ich hier dran verstehe an dem ganzen Ding,
USB. Free Shipping Speech Synthesis Module TTS Pure Text-to-Speech Playback Halli-Lingo AI
Intelligent Speech Broadcast. Alles klar. Die Produktnamen sind einfach immer absolut
Pfeiffert bei AliExpress. Ich weiß nicht, ob das taugt.
Das Notebook explodiert. Die China Software, die sieht immer so geil aus,
Alter. Guckt euch das an. Das sieht immer echt aus. 1995, Alter, der Kram. Wahrscheinlich ist
es auch von 1995. Die sehen alle immer aus, die Dinger, was die da benutzen.
Übrigens, UI-Design aus der Hölle, oder?
Mh, alles klar.
Na dann, next. Aber ich kann es doch nochmal wiederholen.
Wer Elektronikteile kaufen will, jetzt mehr als eins, der ist bei AliExpress wirklich,
wirklich gut dabei. Es gibt viele Sachen auch bei Amazon oder sonst wie in Deutschland zu kaufen,
aber das ist, gerade was Microcontroller angeht, ist das viel, viel teurer. Lass uns das mal
vergleichen. Wir holen uns zum Beispiel mal einen ESP32. Kostaktuell kaum lieferbar sogar. Hier,
24, drei Stück für 25 Euro. AliExpress, drei Stück für 1,80 oder so. Das scheint mir ein
bisschen sehr billig zu sein. Das glaube ich aber kaum. Zumindest gibt es anscheinend hier
zwei Stück für drei Euro. Also wie dem auch sei, es ist auf jeden Fall billiger. Ja, na gut,
aber es ist immer noch billiger, als wenn du es bei Amazon oder sonst wo bestellst. Der einzige
Vorteil, den Amazon hat, ist natürlich, dass die Bestellung meistens ein bisschen schneller geht,
als bei AliExpress. Aber AliExpress selbst, das muss auch keinen Monat mehr dauern,
bis Sachen bei euch eintreffen. Die haben ja mittlerweile Warenlager in EU, also in Spanien
haben die beispielsweise, Niederlande, Frankreich, weiß nicht, ob sie auch welche in Deutschland
haben, aber sie verschicken ja oftmals schon hier irgendwo aus Europa. Das heißt, du musst dir um
Zoll und sowas auch keine Gedanken machen. Und das ist richtig, wobei ich sagen muss, das hatte ich
bisher bei AliExpress auch. Ich wurde einmal versucht zu scammen bei AliExpress, da hat AliExpress
direkt gesagt, Geld zurück. Okay. Habe ich noch nicht bestellt dort, aber ESP32 sind höchst
wahrscheinlich kein Fake, weil ESP32 sind ja China-Chinesen-Chips. Ja, machen sie. Aber an
der Stelle müssten sie ja schon bezahlen. Nur dir kann es dann egal sein. Ja, also AliExpress hat
es lange Zeit gerne gemacht, die haben die Sachen über Holland geschickt und dann war es dann halt
in der EU. Die haben das quasi von China nach Holland und von Holland bzw. von Niederlanden
dann innerhalb der EU verschickt. Da muss man sich mit Zoll-Sachen nicht rumschlagen. Was auch gut
ist, denn ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte bisher bei AliExpress nie Probleme, was in Holland so einfach
ist. Die haben einen großen Hafen und vielleicht sind die, was die Abfertigung angeht, besser. Keine
Ahnung. Zumindest ist Niederlande sehr, sehr beliebt für Einfuhr aus China. Spanien angeblich
auch. Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Hamburg und so aussieht. Wollten die China-Chinesen nicht im
Hamburger Hafen sogar Teile von kaufen? Die sind teilweise sogar noch schneller, wenn es hier
Warenlager in der EU ist. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes hier zu bieten? Die neue
Arbeitswelt der GenZ. Okay, da bin ich jetzt ja mal gespannt. Entweder, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten,
entweder ist diese Reportage von irgendwelchen Ultra-Boomern erstellt, die erzählen, dass es
ja nicht sein kann, dass sie nicht so viel arbeiten wollen oder vielleicht jemand in meinem
Alter, der das ein bisschen realistischer sieht. Ich habe übrigens richtiges, absolutes Lost-Comment
erhalten unter meinem letzten Video auf YouTube. Hallo Leute, gestern irgendwo. Ja, sowas in der
Richtung. Gab es ein paar Leute, die Kommentare drunter geschrieben haben. Wenn Versager darüber
reden, warum sie Versager sind. Ich bin ja froh, dass er so das krasse Crineset-Mindset,
High-Performer-Mindset hat und uns das unter den YouTube-Comments alle mitteilen muss. Die Leute
immer, man. Der einzige Grund, wie ich mir das vorstellen kann, ist, die kriegen selbst nichts
geschissen und haten jetzt dafür rum, dass andere mehr geschissen bekommen. So, mal gucken, was die
hier in der. Ist das überhaupt, ist das überhaupt was Deutsches oder ist es was Österreichisches
oder Schweizerisches oder so? Was ist das? Habe ich noch nie gehört. ORF1, die Österreicher sind
am Start. Okay, okay, mal gucken, wie es in Österreich abgeht. Aber wahrscheinlich haben
die da genauso wenig Bock, 50 Stunden die Woche für kaum Kohle zu arbeiten, für plus minus null am
Monatsende auf dem Konto. Ja, gell? Er könnte in der Zwischenzeit auch. Nein, Leute, der hat es
überhaupt nicht mehr nötig, High-Performer-Arbeit zu leisten. Der hat 5000 Euro passives Einkommen
im Monat. Der hat einfach verstanden, wie es funktioniert. Der ist halt schon auf dem Mount
Everest angekommen. Wir nicht. Sind einfach viel zu low. Ja, morgens, morgens, während er auf dem Klo
sitzt, hat er die 5K passiv schon gemacht. Okay, schauen wir uns das mal an, warum die Gen Z nicht
arbeiten möchte. Oder warum auch immer. Ich weiß ja nicht, was die uns hier sagen wollen. Wurde mir
letztens empfohlen. Das ist ja ein Thema, wo ich immer sage, also meine Meinung dazu kennt ihr ja.
Ich bin der Meinung, die machen das richtig. Erstens muss man mal von den technologischen
Entwicklungen der letzten 50 Jahre auch mal was haben. Ja, also sprich, weniger arbeiten, ohne,
dass es einem scheiße geht dabei. Und zweitens, warum sollte man mehr arbeiten als notwendig,
wenn man genug Geld verdient, um alles das machen zu können, worauf man Bock hat. Oder sagen wir mal
so, einen guten Kompromiss zu finden, aus, ich kann das meiste machen, worauf ich Bock habe,
ohne mich kaputt zu arbeiten. Warum sollte man das nicht machen? Man lebt ja nicht dafür,
nur arbeiten zu gehen. Man lebt nicht dafür, quasi acht Stunden am Tag und sonst nichts von
der Welt mitzubekommen. Also insofern ist das, finde ich das vollkommen verständlich,
wie die Leute das machen. In manchen Berufen geht halt weniger Arbeit nicht. Warum? Warum
sollte das nicht gehen? Ich meine, die könnten dort ohne Probleme auch zwei Leute einstellen,
anstatt einen. Und beide arbeiten nur Halbzeit. Ja, ich verstehe, dass das gewisse Herausforderungen
birgt. Und ich verstehe auch, dass das managementtechnisch für viele Unternehmen sicherlich
nicht so einfach ist. Aber die werden schlicht und ergreifend mit der Zeit gehen müssen. Wenn
die Leute suchen und keine Leute finden, gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder sie machen dicht,
sie geben sich mit geringer qualifizierten, weniger guten Leuten zufrieden. Können sie auch
machen, ja. Was dann aber im Endeffekt auch auf Dauer vielleicht Probleme macht. Oder sie machen
den dritten. Sie machen die dritte Taktik. Sie kacken die Leute mit Geld zu, dass die halt so
viel schaffen. Ja, das denke ich auch. Also ich glaube, das muss man etwas differenzieren an der
Stelle. Es gibt sicherlich Berufe, da ist das jetzt unter den aktuellen Bedingungen nicht möglich.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es prinzipiell nicht möglich ist. Moin Patrick. Also zum Beispiel,
wenn man sich mal anguckt, aktuell so in der alten Krankenpflege und sowas, ja. So nach dem Motto,
man hat drei Leute am Start, für jede Schicht einer und das reicht gerade so, dass die Leute
nicht sterben. Okay. Dann verstehe ich, wenn man sagt, okay, man kann aktuell nicht weniger
arbeiten. Das heißt aber nicht, dass das prinzipiell nicht gehen würde. Man könnte ja
einfach die Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern und indem man anfängt, mehr Leute einzustellen.
Dann wäre allen geholfen. Na gut, außer denen, die es bezahlen müssen natürlich. Aber möglich ist
das sicherlich alles. Ist halt die Frage, ob man gewillt dazu ist, das zu machen. Okay,
mal gucken. Mal gucken, was sie dazu sagen. Ich möchte auf keinen Fall 40 Stunden arbeiten.
Ja, kann ich verstehen. Wer will das schon, ne? Die Jungen sind faul und respektlos. Ah,
das sind ein paar Österreicher hier am Start. Das hört man gleich. Und die Älteren. Wetten,
dass es da genauso ist wie bei uns? Generationen sollten sich immer die Frage stellen,
wenn ich andere Prioritäten habe, wer finanziert mir die? Also, das ist doch ganz einfach,
Adi. Das kann durchaus sein, dass sich da nie was ändert. Unter der Voraussetzung,
dass sie immer genug Leute finden oder im Zweifelsfall auch mit schlechteren Leuten
zufrieden sind, die das machen wollen. Solange das der Fall ist, wird sich da nichts ändern.
Sollten die keine Leute mehr finden, dann müssen sie sich anpassen, weil ansonsten gehen sie pleite
und können dicht machen. Das ist ganz einfach. Und dann ist halt die Frage, was wollen die machen?
Wollen sie sich anpassen oder wollen sie pleite gehen? Oder wollen sie dicht machen? Ja,
gut, dann machen sie halt dicht. Das ist halt auch eine Möglichkeit. Die Boomer brauchen keine Angst
vor ihrer Rente zu haben, weil die kriegen noch ein bisschen was. Die Leute, die Angst um ihre
Rente haben müssen, ist meine Generation. Die darf nämlich auch schön ihr ganzes Leben lang
schaffen und kriegt kaum noch Rente. Deswegen bleibt mir ja nichts anderes übrig, wie noch
Stonks zu machen. Ja, Anpassungen dauern immer ein bisschen. Und man darf jetzt auch, denke ich,
nicht rein den Arbeitgebern oder den Arbeitnehmern die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben. Es geht auch
immer ein bisschen um gesetzliche Rahmenbedingungen und was da möglich ist. Also man kann da sicherlich
Anreize und Rahmenbedingungen so setzen, dass sich das verbessert. Aber gut, das muss sich die
nächsten Jahre überall zeigen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Generation, die jetzt anfängt zu
arbeiten oder gerade eingestiegen ist ins Arbeiten, dass die da noch großartig umdenken. Weil im
Ernst, wer fängt mit dieser Einstellung an zu arbeiten und denkt sich nach fünf Jahren arbeiten,
ach ja, jetzt hätte ich aber schon Bock 40 Stunden zu arbeiten. Das ist ja Blödsinn. Das macht ja
keiner. Das ist eher umgedreht. Die Leute fangen mit 40 Stunden zu arbeiten an und denken sich dann,
oh, da habe ich aber gar keinen Bock drauf. Aber die fangen ja schon mit der Einstellung an,
was ich auch vollkommen nachvollziehen kann. Ich bin ja mittlerweile auch an dem Punkt angekommen.
Und ich mache ja auch Werbung, wo es nur geht dafür, dass die Leute weniger arbeiten,
wenn sie mit der Kohle hinkommen. Das ist so. Ja, so sieht es aus. Wer nicht mit der Zeit geht,
geht mit der Zeit. Korrekt. Ich denke, es sollte jedem freistehen, das zu machen, was er will.
Aber unbezahlt ist schon mal generell irgendwie eine blöde Idee. Es sei denn, es ist dein Unternehmen.
Du bist der Chef. Dann ist natürlich was anderes. Aber ansonsten würde ich nie unbezahlte
Überstunden machen mehr. Selbst wenn es Spaß macht. Hast du vier Tage oder einfach weniger am Tag?
Ich habe vier Tage. Also ich habe 80 Prozent Arbeitszeit. Ich könnte sicherlich auch fünf
Tage arbeiten und dann irgendwie nur irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fünfeinhalb oder was auch immer,
wie viel das rechnerisch wäre. Könnte ich bestimmt auch machen oder sechs Stunden oder so. Aber mache
ich nicht. Okay. Ja, also das ist ein Punkt. Hast du noch? Vielleicht, vielleicht. Also was witzig ist,
bei uns gibt es gerade zwei Leute in Altersteilzeit. Die sind auch bald weg. Das heißt, wir brauchen
gleich demnächst noch ein paar Linux-Fiveheads bei uns. Gucken, ob ich da noch ein paar Leute
vermitteln kann, die ich kenne. Immer direkt Prämie abgreifen. Vielleicht, vielleicht. Muss
ich mal gucken. Also sollte ich mal irgendwann wirklich sagen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen nervt
es mich. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen nervt es mich. Ja, das ist sicherlich eine Option. Aber aktuell
denke ich da eigentlich nicht dran. Ja, und das ist tatsächlich auch was, wo ich sagen muss,
da schlagen wir schon ein bisschen über die Stränge. Also wisst ihr, was eines der ersten
Sachen, als das Thema Chat-GPT und AI so im Mainstream aufgekommen ist? Wisst ihr, was eines
der ersten Sachen war, was ich dort von irgendeinem Politiker oder Politikerin war,
das glaube ich, gehört habe? Wo es überhaupt nicht um die Technik geht. Das erste war,
was ich gehört habe, ist, ja, wir müssen irgendwie einen Ethik-Rat oder irgendwie sowas in der
Richtung gründen für AI-Entwicklung. Und wenn ich sowas schon höre, denke ich mir,
okay, wir schaffen wieder irgendwelche gut bezahlten Stellen, die einfach nur Kohle verbraten
und die wahrscheinlich niemand brauche. Egal. So, gucken wir uns mal an, was die Gen-Z so macht.
Die sieht aber schon ein bisschen älter aus als Gen-Z, oder?
Die Jungen sind faul und respektlos, sagen die Älteren.
Die jungen Generationen sollte mir die Frage stellen, wenn ich andere Prioritäten habe,
wer finanziert mir die? Naja, sie selbst. Sie selbst finanzieren die. Die gehen ja arbeiten.
Die haben aber für sich entschieden, dass es ihnen reicht, was sie bekommen und nicht 40 Stunden
oder sonst was arbeiten müssen, um noch ein bisschen mehr zu bekommen. Die finanzieren
sich das doch genauso selbst wie er. Die Jungen verschwenden ihr Leben in einem
40-Stunden-Job, der sie nicht glücklich macht. Die Gen-Z sagt, nein, gar keinen Bock.
Ich frage mich, wird die Generation Z den Arbeitsmarkt revolutionieren?
Wir sind halt die Generation der Zukunft. Die werden den Arbeitsmarkt genauso
revolutionieren wie alle Generationen davor. Das wird sich anpassen müssen, wer da bleiben will.
Oder nimmt sie sich doch ein bisschen zu wichtig?
Ich besuche Leonie bei ihrer Arbeit. Sie ist Social Media Managerin.
Was sonst? Also, ich will meinen Rant vom letzten Mal nicht wieder wiederholen, ja.
Aber Online-Marketing-Influencer-Marketing-Sachen, Leute, das ist der größte Müllhaufen an Leuten,
die ich kenne. Sagt jetzt natürlich nichts über sie. Ich weiß nicht,
was das für eine Agentur ist. Aber ich habe da so viel Bodensatz an Leuten kennengelernt in den
letzten über zehn Jahren. Also, ich kann da immer kein gutes Haar dran lassen. Das sind meistens
Leute, die lügen dich an, verkaufen dir morgens ihre Oma und mittags verarschen sie dich so.
Also, ich bin prinzipiell skeptisch, wenn irgendjemand sagt, er ist Influencer-Marketing
und Online-Marketing unterwegs. Da gehen bei mir direkt so im Kopf an, so nach dem Motto,
okay, das ist jemand, der dich, ohne mit der Wimper zu zucken, direkt bescheißt.
Bei Digitalwerk, einer Online-Marketing-Agentur. Heute ist sie im Büro anzutreffen.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, Digitalwerk. Also, ich sage nichts, by the way, ihr müsst mich nicht
verklagen oder so. Ich sage nichts über euch, sondern nur meine Erfahrung, die ich bisher mit
Online-Marketing gemacht habe. Allerdings, es gibt durchaus auch gescheite Leute. Ich hatte
beispielsweise nie Probleme mit den Marketingleuten von Hetzner oder damals auch von Elgato oder so
was. Es gibt schon durchaus faire und normale Business-Leute da, keine Frage. Aber der überwiegende
Teil Online-Marketing ist einfach nur kompletter menschlicher Bodensatz. Die kannst du komplett
vergessen. Okay, was machen die denn hier so? Die bauen Autos mit Lüftern, mit Zotac-Lüftern,
Geschäftsfelder. ADTF, was ist das? Habe ich überhaupt das Richtige hier? Influencer. Nee,
die sind das. Wir waren verkehrt, Leute. Wir waren verkehrt. Ja, das sieht auch schon viel
mehr nach Marketing-Stells aus, diese Webseite. Die Webseite laggt? Leute, habt ihr das gesehen?
Guck mal. Alter, ist das Absicht? Nee. Alter, mein Browser hat 90% CPU-Auslastung. In Chrome
ist es, okay, das ist 3D-beschleunigt und mein Chromium hat damit Probleme. Oh, der ganze
Browser laggt, Mann. Das ist keine gute Idee, seine Webseite komplett irgendwie 2D-accelerated,
was auch immer, zu rendern. Lass mal kurz gucken, Chrome. Ja, haben die den Krypto-Miner im
Hintergrund laufen? Boah, Alter, das laggt ja. Okay, jetzt geht es wieder. Leute, ich habe keine
Ahnung, was die eigentlich machen. Die Webseite ist ja pepega hoch 10, Mann. Ja, im Chrome läuft
es bei mir auch flüssig. Chromium hat Probleme. Ach, guck mal, die machen Suchmaschinenoptimierung,
Social, Google und Ads Development. Was machen die denn? Gibt es irgendwas, was sie nicht machen?
Die machen Frontend-Entwicklung, UI, Social Media. Die machen einfach alles. Boah, die haben sogar
einen YouTube-Channel. Okay, also so 0815-Marketingagentur mit ganz viel Zeug noch dabei. Egal,
darum ging es ja in dem Video gar nicht. Was nicht immer der Fall ist, denn sie kann selbst
entscheiden, wann sie im Homeoffice arbeiten möchte. Sehr gut, die Frage ist nur, sie kann
selber entscheiden, wann sie im Homeoffice arbeiten möchte. Ist das so eine Sache, wie ihr habt so
viele Urlaubstage im Jahr, wie ihr wollt und in Wirklichkeit nehmen im Durchschnitt die Leute
eigentlich weniger Urlaub, als ihnen gesetzlich zusteht, damit sie nicht schlecht dastehen? So
nach dem Motto, es kann jeder im Homeoffice arbeiten, aber wir sind so eine junge, agile
Truppe und wir können am besten unser krasses Networking, Socializing, Marketing lokal machen,
deswegen macht der sich ja kein Homeoffice. Weiß man ja nie. Für mich war eigentlich schon immer
klar, dass ich sofort eigentlich in die Arbeitswelt eintauchen möchte. Ich habe
natürlich so ein Reisejahr quasi dazwischen gehabt, das wollte ich schon und habe Australien
und Südostasien eine Reise gemacht, das war schon wichtig für mich. Nach der Matura beginnt Leonie
zu. Da sieht man schon mal, ich bin nicht kompatibel mit Marketingleuten in der Weltanschauung.
Ich glaube für mich wäre so eine Weltreise das Schlimmste, was ich machen könnte. Und so 9 Jahre, nice, ich reise durch die Welt und treffe mich
da mit ganz vielen Leuten. Das ist schon mal das komplette Gegenteil. Wenn du mich fragst, Max,
was willst du machen? Eine Weltreise und dich mit möglichst vielen Leuten treffen oder im Keller
sitzen und was programmieren, dann würde ich sagen, ich sitze lieber im Keller. Zu arbeiten,
heute erinnert sie sich an ihre Anfangszeit zurück. Und habe dann tatsächlich 40 Stunden
gearbeitet. Das war anfangs auch ein echter Schock, muss ich sagen. Das geht jedem so.
Ich habe keine Zeit mehr. Ich habe überhaupt keine Zeit mehr für irgendwas. Und wisst ihr, was das
richtig dumme daran ist? Wenn es Winter ist, du gehst aus dem Haus, wenn es dunkel ist und du
kommst heim, wenn es schon wieder dunkel ist. Aber jetzt wird es schwierig. Weltreise oder im Keller
C++ programmieren? Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Das müsste ich mir mal genauer überlegen. C++
programmieren ein Jahr lang ist schon eine ziemliche Strafe. Weltreise, dann würde ich Rust lernen.
Mein Privatleben hat da echt voll darunter gelitten. Sei es allein nur zum Arzt gehen
oder Dinge erledigen. Paket bei der Post abholen? Man hätte nie gedacht, dass es mal Probleme macht.
Dich sehen und der will dich sehen und da musst du hin und da ein Brunch und hier und so weiter.
Okay, wenn man sozial veranlagt ist, dann macht man ab und zu mal da einen Brunch oder nicht. Oder,
oder alternativ, man macht das so wie ich. Man sitzt für die Arbeit acht Stunden vorm Rechner
und dann sitzt man bei YouTube und Twitch noch mal acht Stunden vorm Rechner und dann geht man
schlafen. Und zwischendurch geht man mal eineinhalb, zwei Stunden draußen sich ein bisschen bewegen,
aber das reicht nicht. Dann reicht die Zeit nicht. Also realistisch betrachtet, okay, lass mal kurz
überlegen. Lass mal kurz überlegen. Ich setze von sieben bis ungefähr 15, 30, 16 Uhr vorm Rechner
für die Arbeit. Dann, sagen wir mal so von 16 Uhr bis 17, 30 oder so. Manchmal, manchmal auch
18 Uhr. Einmal täglich Sport. Das geht sonst nicht. Leute, ich habe das gemerkt. Ich habe
sonst zu viel Kopfschmerzen, Rücken und alles mögliche. Also eineinhalb Stunden Bewegung muss
sein. Und dann sitze ich eigentlich bis 22 Uhr, 22, 30 wieder vorm Computer und mache YouTube
Stelz, Twitch Stelz oder irgendwie Bastelkram. Ja, ich kann es auch nicht verstehen. Ich verstehe
es auch nicht, wie man das aushält. Ich hatte letztens vor ein paar Wochen so ein Einführungs-
neue Mitarbeiter-Event und das waren sieben Stunden Socializen. Das war ganz schlimm auf
der Arbeit, Mann. Danach musste ich erst mal abends hier ein bisschen Stream machen und mich
darüber auskotzen. Egal, wir müssen das Video mal fertig gucken, Leute. Das Video geht nur neun
Minuten und wir sind plötzlich eine Minute und ich labere nur sinnlos rum. Also, okay. Was hat
Leonie denn gerade erzählt, dass sie nicht zum Brunch gehen kann? Ich will dich sehen und der
will dich sehen und da musst du hin und dein Brunch. Dein Brunch, das hört sich so an. So
nach dem Motto, ich habe einen Kalender voll und hier gehen wir essen, hier gehen wir Mittagessen
und da müssen wir irgendwie Party gehen und da muss man uns mit dem treffen und so. Boah, das
sind einfach so Marketing-Leute, so Social Networking-Leute. Das ist ein Lebensstil,
der ist nicht kompatibel zu meinem und meiner wahrscheinlich nicht zu denen ihrem. Aber ich
denke mir, jeder was ihm Freude bringt und Spaß macht und ihn glücklich macht, wenn Leonie das
gefällt, ist es doch vollkommen okay. Nur weil das für mich nichts ist oder weil das für uns
teilweise hier nichts ist, ist es ja in Ordnung. Hier und so weiter, also unmöglich. 40 Stunden
Woche seit demnach nicht mehr zeitgemäß. Die Leute haben gelebt für die Arbeit,
so das war da einfach das Ding. Meine Oma zum Beispiel, die sagt immer, die Leute sind ja nicht
ausgegangen, es ist ja niemand essen gegangen. Heutzutage sehen die Leute das anders. Okay,
sorry, ich muss nochmal unter... die sieht aus, das ist jetzt nicht das, was ich sagen wollte,
die sieht aus wie die Frau von Prinz Harry ein bisschen, oder? Ich kenne mich in dieser
Adelsgeschichte nicht wirklich aus, das ist glaube ich die einzige, die ich kenne,
aber die sieht ein bisschen aus wie die Frau von Prinz Harry. Nicht? Naja. Okay,
dann nicht, Chat. Chat, wenn ihr das sagt, dann nicht. Okay, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte,
Moment. Och, die sieht ja schon ein bisschen ähnlich aus. Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist,
sie hat ja gerade erzählt, was ihr Opa und ihre Oma und so immer erzählt hat. Also es gibt eine
Sache, die hat mein Opa immer erzählt und da merkt man einfach, dass der aus einer anderen Zeit kommt.
Mein Opa kommt aus einer Zeit, also ich meine es nicht Zweiter Weltkrieg und sowas, oder mein
Opa kam aus einer Zeit, da war das vollkommen undenkbar, dass man zu seinem Chef gesagt hat,
ich habe jetzt Feierabend, ich gehe jetzt heim. Oder generell gesagt hat, das ist jetzt aber keine
so gute Idee, anders wäre besser oder irgendwas in der Richtung. Mein Opa kommt aus einer Zeit,
was sein Chef gesagt hat, war Gesetz, was irgendwie damals sein Lehrer gesagt hat,
war Gesetz, was die Frau gesagt hat, nein nicht wirklich, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Wenn die
Oma gesagt hat, wir müssen das jetzt machen, dann wurde das gemacht, so nach dem Motto. Also
mein Opa war halt sehr davon überzeugt, derjenige, der quasi über ihm steht und was zu sagen hat,
ist wichtiger und das muss man alles so befolgen und sowas. Zumindest, der hat immer eine Sache zu
mir gesagt, mein Opa. Und zwar, das war schon ganz lang, solange ich denken kann. Und wahrscheinlich
hat er das auch schon beim Kindergarten gesagt. Und zwar hat mein Opa immer gesagt,
ey warte mal ab, bis du in die Schule kommst. Also was weiß ich, ich habe mein Opa genervt mit
irgendwas oder ich habe ihm gesagt, das ist Blödsinn, was er erzählt oder was auch immer.
Zumindest immer, wenn mein Opa der Meinung war, du wirst später mal nicht immer deinen Kopf
durchsetzen können, dann hat mein Opa immer den gleichen Spruch gebracht. Der hat immer gesagt,
warte mal ab, bis du in die Schule kommst, dann wirst du noch Schwerkordel nachgeben müssen.
Das wird man wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich verstehen. Kordel ist sowas wie Schnur auf oder
oder Strick oder sowas auf Hessisch. Das heißt so viel wie übersetzt, du wirst nicht immer deinen
Kopf durchsetzen können. Er hat immer gesagt, warte mal ab, bis du in die Schule kommst,
dann wirst du Schwerkordel nachgeben müssen. So, dann bin ich in die Schule gekommen und
weiß nicht, war das nie so richtig der Fall. Dann hat er gemeint, ja, warte mal ab,
bis du in die weiterführende Schule kommst, dann wirst du noch Schwerkordel nachgeben müssen.
War wieder nicht so der Fall. Warte mal ab, bis du deine Ausbildung machst, dann wirst du noch
Schwerkordel nachgeben müssen. Ja, warte mal, bis du richtig arbeiten gehst, dann wirst du sehen,
da kannst du nicht alles so machen, da wirst du noch Schwerkordel nachgeben müssen. Und
dieser Punkt ist bis jetzt nie eingetreten. Selbstverständlich in gewisser Weise ganz
Unrecht hat er nicht. Du kannst nicht immer hundertprozentig das machen, worauf du Bock hast,
aber es ist ein Unterschied zu dem, wie es mein Opa gesehen hat. Mein Opa war jemand so nach dem
Motto, wenn der Chef sagt, jetzt springst du aus dem Fenster, dann springst du aus dem Fenster,
übertrieben gesagt. Okay, jetzt hätte er wahrscheinlich gesagt, warte mal ab,
bis du in die Rente gehst. Keine Ahnung. Mein Opa gibt es ja leider nicht. Übrigens,
ich habe mal vor Jahren ein Video mit meinem Opa aufgenommen. Das ist mein Opa. Er legt keinen
Wert darauf, in das Gelaber der großen Menge zu kommen. Alles klar. Und solche Dinger. Zumindest
das war halt so sein Standardspruch, den er immer gebracht hat. Du wirst noch Schwerkordel
nachgeben müssen. In gewisser Weise ganz Unrecht hat er nicht. Natürlich kann man nicht immer
hundertprozentig das machen, was man will, aber in der heutigen Zeit ist es nicht mehr so,
dass alles automatisch Gesetz ist. Die Arbeitswelt hat sich insofern schon ein bisschen verändert. Es
wird auch sicherlich nicht überall, aber es wird oftmals auch geschätzt oder sogar verlangt,
dass man Leute hat, die ein bisschen mitdenken. Also nur, weil jetzt irgendjemand sagt,
wir brauchen unbedingt, stell dir vor, der Abteilungsleiter kommt zu dir und du bist
Netzwerktechniker und sagst, hey, wir haben ein Projekt, das hat Zugriffsprobleme, mach jetzt
sofort mal Firewall-Freischaltung. Und dann sagst du, ja, aber wenn wir die Firewall-Freischaltung
machen, ist das keine so gute Idee, denn dann haben wir public im Internet auf einmal acht
Webserver hängen. Und dann wird der Abteilungsleiter entweder sagen, ist mir scheißegal,
mach trotzdem, oder er wird sagen, okay, ist vielleicht auch keine so gute Idee. Natürlich
ist es bei mir auch schon vorgekommen, dass er dann gesagt hat, also das ist jetzt ein Beispiel,
natürlich ist es bei mir auch schon vorgekommen, dass er dann gesagt hat, ja, dann mach trotzdem,
wie gesagt, ihr könnt es auf alle möglichen Sachen übertragen. Und dann denke ich mir an
der Stelle immer, das ist ja kein Kordel nachgeben in dem Sinn, das ist, ich habe gesagt, das ist eine
scheiß Idee und ich bin fein raus, wenn dann wirklich scheiße passiert. Weil wenn scheiße
passiert, kann ich sagen, naja, wer hätte ja auch schon damit rechnen können, dass das Freischalten
von Port 80 auf interne Server eine blöde Idee ist. Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte ich euch nicht
gesagt. Also deswegen, das, was mein Opa da propheziert hat, ist nie eingetreten in der
krassen Weise, wie er es gesagt hat, aber natürlich zum Teil hatte er nicht unrecht.
Okay, jetzt habe ich keine Ahnung mehr, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Die Leute sind ja nicht ausgegangen, ist ja niemand essen gegangen.
Das stimmt wohl auch. Also ich glaube, gerade die Generation von meiner Oma, Opa, ich meine,
die haben ja nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg das ja alles noch mit aufgebaut und sonst was,
da war mit, da war im Prinzip, wir haben ein Klo daheim, schon absoluter Luxus und später,
wir haben sogar ein Auto oder einen Fernseher, war absoluter Luxus. Da sind wir heute schon
ein bisschen verwöhnt. Das stimmt schon, aber man muss halt auch mal sehen, es hat sich viel getan,
die letzten 80 Jahre. Und wir haben viele neue Technologie am Start, die letzten 80 Jahre über.
Wir haben auch vieles verbessert, auch wenn in der heutigen Zeit es irgendwie im Trend ist,
zu sagen, es ist alles scheiße und das ist so schlimm wie noch nie, hat man den Eindruck,
aber es hat sich enorm vieles verbessert, die letzten 80 Jahre. Sicherlich nicht alles,
wir haben auch andere Probleme, aber es hat sich vieles verbessert im Vergleich zu früher.
Und gerade was wir an technologischen Möglichkeiten haben, ich denke,
irgendwann ist auch mal der Punkt gekommen, wo man das, wo man das irgendwie ausnutzen muss.
Wo man auch einfach mal sagen kann, okay, ich habe Hunger, ich bestelle mir jetzt was bei
Lieferando, ich habe keinen Bock mehr einkaufen zu gehen, ich lasse mir was,
lasse mir vom Rewe was liefern oder ach, ich gehe jetzt einfach mal um die Ecke was futtern.
Ich meine, das Durchschnittsgehalt ist die letzten so und so viel gestiegen. Das kann
man jetzt einfach mal machen. Es hat sich ja auch vieles verbessert, die letzten 80 Jahre.
Also ich denke, der Vergleich zwischen den Generationen ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber ich denke, wir sind echt an dem Punkt angelangt, dass man jetzt mal sagen kann,
wir sollten von der Technologie, die sich in den letzten Jahrzehnten entwickelt hat,
auch langsam mal was haben. Und nicht einfach 40 Stunden durcharbeiten für Dinger,
die nicht wirklich so relevant sind und nicht wirklich wichtig sind.
Wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie viele Bullshit-Bürokratie-Jobs es mittlerweile gibt,
die wahrscheinlich die nächsten Jahre über schlicht und ergreifend ersetzt werden werden
durch irgendwelche Bots. Egal, gucken wir mal weiter.
Heutzutage sehen die Leute das anders, vor allem eben die Leute aus meiner Generation.
Und da hat die Generation auch recht. Und ich kann euch sagen, viele aus meiner Generation,
ich bin ja Generation Y quasi, die sehen das auch so. Meine Generation ist gespalten,
was das angeht. Viele sind noch so ein bisschen, viele in meiner Generation, in meinem Alter,
so 38, 39, sagen wir mal 35 bis 45, so die Generation, die ist da so ein bisschen gespalten.
Du hast welche, das sind die Ultra-Boomer vor dem Herrn, also die sind mehr Boomer,
als Boomer je sein könnten. Und du hast welche, wie ich, die ein bisschen mit der Zeit gegangen
sind. Die sitzen jetzt vorm Rechner und reden in Twitch-Emotes oder auch irgendwas dazwischen.
Ich glaube, das hat sich so ein bisschen entschieden zu dem Zeitpunkt. Alles so in
dem Dreh, würde ich sagen, so in dem Dreh 1995 rum. 1995 so in dem Dreh rum hat sich das alles
entschieden. Leute in meiner Generation, die damals aufgeschlossen waren, was Technik gegenüber
angeht, Internet, Computer daheim und solche Geschichten, die sind keine super krassen Boomer
geworden und werden es wahrscheinlich auch nie, weil die immer dank Internet und Technik so ein
bisschen am Puls der Zeit sind. Sicherlich, ich finde vieles auch schwachsinnig. Ich habe
beispielsweise, und das ist vielleicht ein bisschen der Boomer in mir, ich habe den Hype
um TikTok nie so wirklich nachvollziehen können. Oder auch, warum die Leute Snapchat, okay,
warum die Leute Snapchat verwenden, konnte ich nachvollziehen, weil sie dachten, man kann Nacktbilder
verschicken, die sich automatisch wieder löschen, was ja schon ein Trugschluss war und mittlerweile
es ja sogar Sachen gibt, um Bilder zu recoveren und sowas. Das habe ich nie so richtig verstanden,
aber ich glaube, in meiner Generation hat sich das so alles ein bisschen entschieden, so im 1995 rum.
Die, die damals Technologie, Internet, Computer daheim scheiße fanden, die sitzen heute wie die
größten Boomer mit anderen Boomern zusammen beim Stammtisch und erzählen, dass sie wissen,
wie die Welt funktionieren müsste, wenn sie das sagen hätten, wäre die Welt viel besser,
so typische Stammtisch-Geschwätze. Und es gibt so ein bisschen eher technologieinteressierte
Generation Y-Leute wie mich, die halt durch Internet und Heimcomputer und vielleicht auch,
weil sie in der IT arbeiten, so ein bisschen immer so am Puls der Zeit mit sind. Ich glaube,
meine Generation ist da sehr gespalten in dieser Richtung. Eine Sache, die mich ja persönlich auch
immer schockiert, ist, wie wenig Ahnung von Technologie, die diese Generation hier hat.
Ich dachte eigentlich früher, als ich angefangen habe mit Internet, Computer und sowas, dass es
überhaupt keine Diskussionen und Fragen mehr geben wird bei der nächsten Generation. Weil bei
mir war das alles neu und auch sehr in den Kinderschuhen alles. Und ich dachte mir so,
die Generation, die nach mir kommt, die wächst damit auf und für die ist es überhaupt gar kein
Ding mehr. Generation Z wird niemals fragen müssen, wie schließe ich mein DSL-Modem an.
Das machen die quasi so schon im Kindergarten, so nach dem Motto dachte ich damals. Da habe
ich allerdings falsch gedacht. Generation Z hat heute ganz andere Probleme mit Technik. Generation
Z hat das entgegengesetzte Problem wie die Generation vor mir. Die Generation vor mir
hat das Problem oder teilweise auch noch die Leute in meiner Generation. Für die war Technik was
Neues und die haben da nie Zugang für gefunden und waren halt komplett lost. Heute ist es so,
die Leute sind von Anfang an mit Technik aufgewachsen, die funktioniert. Und das ist das
Problem. Die mussten sich nie mit Technik auseinandersetzen, die nicht funktioniert.
Und wenn mal was nicht funktioniert, sind die auch komplett lost. Die haben keinen Plan von.
Wenn ich mir heute angucke, geht mal Leute, gutefrage.net und sucht mal nach PC-Problemen.
Okay, gute Frage ist immer kein gutes Beispiel dafür, weil das komplett voll ist von Ultra
PP-Gas überhaupt. Die sind komplett lost teilweise. Okay, jetzt muss ich aber echt mal das Video gucken.
Es gibt einfach so viele Dinge, die man ausprobieren kann, machen kann, statt zu
arbeiten. Das ist wahr, das würde ich auch unterstreichen. Man kann auch einfach nicht
arbeiten, anstatt zu arbeiten und machen, worauf man Bock hat.
Eine Einstellung, die bei älteren Generationen oft auf Unverständnis stößt.
Meine Wahrnehmung von dem Ganzen ist, dass die jüngeren Mitarbeiter im Grunde genommen
ziemlich schwer zu motivieren sind, überhaupt Arbeit und mehr Leistung zu bringen.
Ja, liegt vielleicht daran, dass das, was das Unternehmen sagt oder dass die Arbeit,
die sie haben, halt schlicht und ergreifend langweilig ist oder halt wie vor 50 Jahren
und keiner Bock drauf hat, das zu machen. Ich kann euch sagen, es gibt durchaus Arbeiten,
die mich auch nicht motivieren. Ich meine, wenn das halt so ein Ultra-Boomer-Unternehmen ist,
muss man sich doch nicht wundern, dass die aktuelle Generation da wenig motiviert ist,
die Arbeit durchzuführen. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, haben die sicherlich auch gelernt,
dass nur, wenn man sich reinhängt alleine, das nicht zwangsläufig zu mehr Bezahlung führen muss.
Gerade in so richtig krassen Boomer-Unternehmen ist es halt so, dass sie bei vielen modernen
Sachen komplett den Anschluss verloren haben. Also beziehungsweise auch bei ein bisschen
moderneren Denkweisen den Anschluss verloren haben. Zum Beispiel ein Punkt,
den es bei ganz vielen so Oldschool-Boomer-Unternehmen gibt, ist, der einzige Weg,
Karriere zu machen, ist Management. Und das ist, finde ich, komplett der falsche Ansatz.
Das haben viele etwas modernere, gerade ein bisschen mehr auf Technologie setzende
Unternehmen verstanden. Es macht keinen Sinn, die einzige Karrieremöglichkeit zu bieten,
ins Management zu gehen, weil gute Techniker sind nicht zwangsläufig gute Manager. Umgedreht
selbstverständlich auch nicht. Ich würde sogar sagen, ein Bruchteil guter Techniker sind gute
Manager. Das heißt, es macht wenig Sinn, nur weil jemand super Fiveheader ist und der beste
Programmierer ist in der Firma, der beste Entwickler in dem Unternehmen ist, den auf
einmal zum Teamleiter für die Entwicklung zu machen. Das macht keinen Sinn. Viele etwas
modernere Unternehmen haben das verstanden, aber gerade viele alteingesessene Boomer-Unternehmen
nicht. So, das Problem ist jetzt natürlich, dass der Techniker, der der beste Programmierer im
Unternehmen ist, sicherlich ja auch eine Karriereperspektive haben will. Und wenn man
ihm sagt, hey, die einzige Möglichkeit, dass du bei uns mehr Geld verdienst, ist Teamleiter zu
werden, dann wird er sagen, leckt mich, ich will kein Teamleiter werden. Entweder sagt er dann,
ich mache das, ist ein schlechter Teamleiter, oder aber er sagt, okay, ich sehe hier für mich
keine Karrieremöglichkeiten und sucht das weiter und sucht sich ein anderes Unternehmen. Das wird
im Endeffekt passieren. Deswegen haben viele etwas moderner denkendere Unternehmen, das Peter-Prinzip
ist ja die Geschichte mit, wir befördern den, der am wenigsten das kann. Etwas moderner denkendere
Unternehmen haben dann schon, sind dann schon auf die Idee gekommen, okay, wir müssen sowohl einen
Management-Karriereweg bieten, als auch einen Fachtechnik-Karriereweg. Was, finde ich, auch der
richtige Ansatz ist. Also du kannst zum Beispiel als Entwickler, wenn du, also die Standardsachen
sind ja sowas in der Richtung, wie du fängst als Junior-Entwickler an, dann wirst du was auch immer
Entwickler, irgendwann wirst du Senior-Entwickler, irgendwann wirst du vielleicht Experte-Entwickler,
dann wirst du irgendwann mal Architekt, was auch immer. Es gibt ja unterschiedlichste,
unterschiedlichste Sachen. Und das Wichtige daran ist, dass du bei diesem Karriereweg nicht auf
einmal Personalverantwortung oder Personalmanagement-Sachen aufgedrückt bekommst,
was du nicht machen willst, sondern du bekommst trotzdem mehr Verantwortung, so ist das nicht,
allerdings nicht in Form von klassischen Management-Aufgaben. Du wirst dann vielleicht
Hauptansprechpartner für eine bestimmte Technologie im Unternehmen, dass man sagt,
okay, das ist der Typ, ist unser Experte für, was weiß ich, Authentifizierung oder sowas.
Und dann hast du dann an der Stelle jemanden sitzen, der ein guter Entwickler ist, der Ahnung
hat von diesem Thema und der quasi Ansprechpartner ist für alle möglichen Sachen, wenn einer nicht
weiß, was Sache ist zum Thema Authentifizierung, dann fragt er halt den. Also sprich, die Variante,
dass man nicht nur Karrieremöglichkeiten bietet in Form von Management, ist was,
was so Oldschool-Boomer-Unternehmen wohl vollkommen fremd ist, aber was unglaublich wichtig ist,
wenn man ein bisschen moderner denkt, wenn man auch nicht will, dass einem die fähigen Leute
wegrennen. So, weiter geht's. Das ist übrigens zu gutem... Das ist auch ein Punkt,
den hätte mein Opa komplett anders gesehen. Ich sehe das übrigens genauso wie du. Die Aufgabe
einer Führungskraft ist nicht einfach nur, ich bin der Chef und bin viel geiler als ihr. Die
Aufgabe einer Führungskraft ist, seinen Job ordentlich zu machen und die Aufgabe von Technik
ist... Also eine Führungskraft hat genauso einen sinnvollen Job, den es zu erledigen gilt,
wie der Techniker, der zu dem Team gehört. Früher war es eher so, ich bin der Chef,
dementsprechend bin ich was Besseres. Das ist noch so die Zeit von meinem Opa. Das
sollte aber nie das Verhältnis von Techniker zu Manager sein. Sicherlich ist das in dieser
Denkweise bestimmt noch in irgendwelchen Unternehmen verbreitet, aber ich bin der
Meinung, alle haben einen wichtigen Job. Unter anderem der Job eines Teamleiters ist es,
die Leute ihre Arbeit machen zu lassen, also beziehungsweise ihnen zu ermöglichen,
dass sie ihre Arbeit machen. Was auch heißt, zum Beispiel, wenn es Probleme gibt, die entsprechend
zu kommunizieren, die Pläne, die oben weiter im Management getroffen werden, ordentlich dem Team
gegenüber zu präsentieren. Wenn es Probleme gibt, zu vermitteln, für Voraussetzungen zu sorgen,
dass sie erfüllt sind, dass man gescheit arbeiten kann und letztendlich, das ist eines der wichtigsten
Punkte, Vorgaben machen, auf die man sich verlassen kann. Und dann, wenn die Leute halt
irgendwas richtig machen anhand der Vorgaben, aber das trotzdem in die Hose geht, klar zu sagen,
Leute, eure Vorgaben sind scheiße, nicht meine Leute, die das erledigt haben. Also das sind so
Dinge, die würde man von einem guten Teamleiter und einem guten Chef, unter anderem gibt es
sicherlich noch mehr, erwarten. Und diese Sache mit hier ist gut gelaufen und sowas, das ist was,
das hätte mein Opa komplett anders gesehen. Mein Opa hat gesagt, er hätte gesagt so nach dem Motto,
wir sind hier nicht im Kindergarten, hier wird nicht gelobt, hier wird gearbeitet, so nach dem
Motto. Das ist auch, finde ich, so eine typische Baustellenaussage, vielleicht schon. Könnte ich
mir sowas auch vorstellen. Aber das Problem dabei ist, Eigenantrieb ist deutlich motivierender,
wie schimpfen. Wie soll ich das anders, wie soll ich, versteht man, was ich meine? Also,
du kannst jetzt einem sagen, alter, du bist so scheiße, wenn du weiter so scheiße bist,
dann werfen wir dich raus. So, extrem gesagt, ja. Und man denkt sich dann so nach dem Motto,
der ist jetzt sicherlich super krass motiviert, weil wenn es weiter scheiße oder wenn es irgendwie
schlägt, dann weiß er, dass er rausgewinnt. Nee, das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Der wird wahrscheinlich
eher komplett unmotiviert sein und permanent sich überlegen, okay, wie kann ich was machen,
dass es möglichst wenig auf mich zurückfällt, was dann oftmals wiederum dazu führt, dass er
möglichst wenig macht, weil wenn er nichts macht, kann er nichts falsch machen. Das heißt,
es ist tatsächlich besser. Man sagt den Leuten so nach dem Motto, oh, hier, du musst ja nicht
sagen, du bist der geilste ever, der je gelebt hat oder sowas. Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Aber man kann durchaus sagen, wenn Projekte gut gelaufen sind, mal Ansprache halten und sagen,
dass es gut gelaufen ist. Oder, boah, das war jetzt hier seit fünf Monaten, hat es keiner
rausgekriegt. Ey, guck mal hier, was wir für schlaue Leute im Team haben. Einige Leute haben
das geschafft und der und der hat sich da richtig reingehängt und so. Also, sprich,
es ist immer besser, du motivierst die Leute, indem du sie halt quasi bestärkst in dem,
was sie machen, anstatt ihnen zu sagen, sie sind scheiße und sie werden sonst rausgeschmissen.
Also dadurch, dass die Leute von sich aus motiviert sind, klappt das viel besser. Das ist auch was,
was viele Boomer-Unternehmen noch nicht verstanden haben. Natürlich, es kann nicht immer nur alles
ist toll geben. Es gibt auch durchaus Sachen, die sind scheiße gelaufen. Da kann man nicht sagen,
ja, an sich ist das eigentlich alles ganz toll, aber wir haben hier noch leichte Unschärfen
entdeckt. Du musst schon sagen, wenn was kacke ist. Aber wichtig ist, dass man nicht sagt nach
dem Motto, ey, hier ist was kaputt gegangen und wir suchen jetzt nach drei Monaten, drei Monate
lang den, der sich eingeloggt hat, um ihn danach zwei Wochen lang zu flamen und täglich im Daily
auszulachen, so nach dem Motto getrieben gesagt. Sondern wichtig ist zu sagen, ey, das ist scheiße
und lasst uns doch mal gucken, wie es dazu gekommen ist. Also sprich, warum ist das System
ausgefallen? Wie ist es dazu gekommen, dass wir 24 Stunden Ausfall haben? So, dann findet man
sicherlich Fehler, die die Mitarbeiter begangen haben, aber es ist ganz selten einer, der es
verkackt hat. Meistens ist es eine Verkettung von Umständen und oftmals auch eine Zusammenarbeit
von Leuten. So, der Erste hat nicht richtig gesagt, was er haben will. Der Nächste hat es falsch
interpretiert. Der Dritte hat eine Anleitung copy-pasted, die jemand anderes geschrieben hat,
die er nicht verstanden hat. Das sind meistens so Verkettungen verschiedener Sachen. Es ist selten
einer, auf den man jetzt deuten kann. Es gibt Ausnahmen. Ich habe euch das ja schon erzählt.
Wir hatten mal einen Storage-Experte, der gesagt hat, er ist Storage-Experte und am Ende hat er
halt Sachen falsch konfiguriert im Storage, für das er Experte ist und ist dann erstmal fünf
Stunden abgehauen Mittagessen und man hat am Ende rausgekriegt, ja, er hat Mist gebaut, ist
abgehauen, hat nie was gesagt. Ja, den haben sie dann relativ schnell wieder raus entsorgt. Das
sind aber auch so Sachen, da bist du echt pp-ger, wenn du sowas machst. Hätte der gesagt, oh Mist,
Leute, ich glaube, ich habe mich gerade verklickt, lasst uns mal gucken. Hätte keiner irgendwas
dagegen gesagt. Aber meistens ist es ja mehrere. Und was wichtig ist, da nicht zu gucken, wer hat
am meisten Scheiße gebaut, um dann zu sagen, du machst nie wieder Änderungen an produktiven
Systemen oder so einen Blödsinn. Sondern, was übrigens auf meiner alten Arbeit genauso passiert
ist, da gab es richtig Stress mit jemand Neuem. Das war auch, egal, erzähle ich euch jetzt nicht.
Sondern man guckt, warum ist der Ablauf so kacke gewesen. Und wenn man sich überlegt,
warum ist der Ablauf so kacke gewesen, kann es durchaus an mehreren Stellen gelegen haben. Ich
habe ja schon oft genug Videos zu gemacht, zu Systemausfällen und so was. Das lag meistens
an verschiedenen Stellen. Und wichtig ist doch nur, dass man daraus lernt und weiß, okay,
wir haben es verkackt an den und den Stellen. Vielleicht sollte man in Zukunft sich mal
überlegen, wie können wir das anpassen, dass das so nicht mehr passiert. Und lange Rede,
kurzer Sinn. Ist das irgendwelche Ami-Memes? Hältst du Management überhaupt für eine
sinnvolle Tätigkeit? Ja, klar. Es gibt leider nicht viele fähige Manager. Aber ich halte das
für wichtig. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie das heißt. Es gibt so eine ungeschriebene Regel,
da gibt es, glaube ich, auch irgendeinen Spruch für, wie das heißt. Und zwar,
dass Projekte relativ schnell 80% fertig sind und die letzten 20% quasi fünfmal länger dauern,
wie die ersten 80%. Da gibt es irgendwie so eine 80-20-Regel. Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und
das passiert, wenn du Techniker fragst nach dem Status. Heißt das so? Es sagt, dass 80% der
Ergebnisse mit 20% des Gesamtaufwands erreicht werden. Ja, genau. Im Prinzip ist es das,
was ich meine. Im Prinzip ist es das, was ich meine. Und das kommt raus, wenn du nur Techniker
nach dem Status fragst. Das ist aber auch verständlich, weil ganz im Ernst, wenn man
irgendwas programmiert, man weiß ja, was am Ende rauskommen soll. Und wenn man was programmiert,
so nach dem Motto, man hat es am Laufen, es funktioniert prinzipiell, man weiß, wie alles
geht, man muss es quasi nur noch ordentlich machen, dann denkt man gerne mal, man ist 80%
fertig. Aber dieses, man muss das nur noch ordentlich machen, das ist halt alles, was der
eigentliche Aufwand ist. Weil zu diesem, man muss es nur noch ordentlich machen, zählt nämlich auch,
dass wenn in einem halben Jahr jemand sagt, ey, können wir da noch was einbauen, dass das geht.
Bei dem wild gestrickten anderen eher nicht. Und deswegen ist es wichtig, dass es Projektmanager
gibt und Manager insgesamt, aber die müssen halt auch was können. Die müssen das halt auch
gescheit machen. Und da gibt es tatsächlich wiederum nicht so viel Gescheite, die das auf
die Reihe bekommen. Angeführt durch eine gute, gleichgestellte Karriere wie bei uns, ist das
tatsächlich so, dass du nur mit Teamleiter und Bereichsleiter steigen kannst, nicht unbedingt
Teil in dem. Ja, und du kannst ihm auch sagen, also du kannst ihm auch Beispiele bringen. Sag
ihm, Google macht es auch so. Also bei Google ist das ja auch so. Oder bei Microsoft oder bei
Meta oder sonst wie. Ist das eigentlich bei allen größeren, ein bisschen IT- oder technikfokussierten
Unternehmen oder Unternehmen mit einer unerheblichen IT-Abteilung so. Du hast,
oder du musst doch nicht bei IT sein. Du hast in vielen Unternehmen heutzutage fachliche
Karrieremöglichkeiten und so Management-Karrieremöglichkeiten. Also du kannst dir auch
ruhig ein paar Beispiele raussuchen, wo das ist und dass es dort auch wunderbar, wunderbar
funktioniert. Und es liegt ja auf der Hand. Die Stärken eines guten Technikers sind, ist die
Technik und nicht irgendwie Personalmanagement oder sowas. Das sollten alle so machen. Leider
machen das nicht viele so. Das ist übrigens ein Punkt, der auch für so einen guten Teamleiter
zählt. Ich meine damit nicht, dass der Teamleiter bei jeder Kleinigkeit sagen soll, wir haben aber
die geilsten Leute, wir sind die Besten und ihr habt das so toll gemacht. Das wirkt auch nicht
glaubwürdig. Aber zum Beispiel, ja, es ist ein Ausfall. Irgendjemand meldet sich nachts an, weil
er zufällig auf sein Handy geguckt hat oder so und er wird angerufen. Der fixt den Ausfall in zwei
Stunden und alle gehen wieder pennen. Gehen wir mal von dem Fall aus. Dann wird ja irgendjemand
im höheren Management sagen, okay, was da passiert? Und dann gibt es die Variante, entweder
man konzentriert sich, das ist das, wie es in miesen Unternehmen läuft, man konzentriert sich
rein auf Plain Game. Wie konnte das sein? Wer hat es verkackt, dass es kaputt gegangen ist? Oder aber
es fällt vielleicht auch mal nach dem Motto, hier Wahnsinns-Einsatz von dem und dem Mitarbeiter und
hier Fachkompetenz gezeigt, dass er das nachts um drei Uhr auf die Schnelle hinbekommen hat. Wir
geben das mal weiter an seinen Teamleiter und der muss das dann auch weitergeben. Ja, also sprich,
dass dann ein Teamleiter dir auch mal sagt, ich meine, ich erwarte ja nicht, dass mich der
Vorstandsvorsitzende anruft nachts oder morgens und sagt, hey, Max, cool gemacht. Ich meine, ey,
warum nicht? Aber das würde ich ja nicht erwarten. Aber wenn sowas fällt, würde ich von meinem
Teamleiter erwarten, dass er sowas auch weitergibt. Dass er sich nicht einfach nur loben lässt dafür,
was er für tolle Leute im Team hat, sondern dass er auch noch mal sagt, Jungs, das kam richtig gut
an und der Vorstand bedankt sich noch mal für den Nachteinsatz oder sowas. Reicht ja voll und
ganz aus. Ja, dann muss er sich nicht wundern, wenn die Leute ihm wegrennen. Das sind Leute,
die mal ein paar Führungskräfte-Seminare besuchen sollten. Das tritt aber auch oftmals leider in so
ein bisschen Oldschool-Unternehmen auf. Da werden dann Leute Chef und haben eigentlich,
wie soll man sagen, eher so eine merkwürdige Vorstellung im Kopf, die auch nie korrigiert
wird. Die sind quasi so, wie soll man sagen, wie man beim Programmieren sagt, man hat sich selbst
beigebracht. Ja, die haben sich das dann auch selbst beigebracht. Und es gibt durchaus sinnvolle
Kurse, die man als angehender Teamleiter, angehende Führungskraft machen kann, die einem
ein bisschen was beibringen in dieser Richtung. Das ist nicht verkehrt, das zu machen. Gerade,
wenn man vorher damit nichts zu tun hat. Das sollten auch viele mal machen. Naja,
Führungskräfte ist aber Manager-Karriereweg. Ich weiß aber, das würde ich schon mal alles
so in die gleiche Schiene schieben. Ja, so muss das sein. Ich habe davon keine Ahnung,
ich wäre ein mega schlechter Teamleiter, das weiß ich. Meine Leute, ihr wisst, wie gut ich
mit Leuten klarkomme, auf Dauer und in gehäufter Form. Ich wäre ein richtig schlechter Teamleiter.
Ich glaube, das ist auch was, wo sich jeder mal Gedanken drüber machen kann. Es ist ja überhaupt
nicht schlimm, sich mal zumindest darüber bewusst zu werden, was man gut kann und was nicht.
Man muss nicht alles gut können. Oftmals kann man auch Sachen nicht gut, weil man da schlicht
und ergreifend keinen Antrieb dazu hat, sich darin zu verbessern. Das ist auch nicht schlimm. Man
muss sich nicht für alles interessieren. Dann macht das deine Teamleiterin aber verkehrt. Also,
es ist ja durchaus sinnvoll, sich technische Zusammenhänge erklären zu lassen als Teamleiter.
Das war bei meiner alten Arbeit auch so. Da kam öfters, aber man muss sagen, mein Chef,
der hat auch ein VMWare-Zertifikat und hat lange Zeit Virtualisierung in Linux gemacht. Also,
mein Alter vom alten, der kannte sich da ganz gut aus. Dem konnte man technische
Zusammenhänge erklären. Hätte ich jetzt einen Teamleiter gehabt, der technisch gar keine Ahnung
hat, dann hätte ich gehofft, dass er das irgendwann mal realisiert, beziehungsweise dass man mit der
Zeit erkennt, dass es nicht unbedingt die beste Idee ist, ihm technische Sachen zu erklären und
er versucht, die technischen Sachen dann weiter zu erklären, sondern ich finde, es ist nicht verkehrt,
wenn man das in Zusammenarbeit mit seinem Chef macht. Also, zum Beispiel, wenn Abteilungsleiter
Runde ist, wo aktuelle Produktionsprobleme, aktuelle Projekte, was auch immer vorgestellt
werden, da finde ich es gar nicht so weit hergeholt zu sagen, okay, man nimmt sich als Teamleiter mal
den Experten für das jeweilige Thema mit, wenn der will. Also, ich bin auch kein Fan von, man zwingt
jemanden dazu, der überhaupt keinen Bock auf solche Vorträge und sowas hat. Aber es kann schon Sinn
machen, zu sagen, hey, wir nehmen den Experten einfach mit und nicht einfach nur übrigens hier
nächsten Montag ist da und da Abteilungsleiter Runde, sondern nee, man setzt sich vielleicht im
Vorfeld mal zusammen, lässt sich das erklären, überlegt sich, okay, was können wir denen erzählen,
dann nimmt man den Experten mit, falls sie den noch nie gesehen haben, sagen wir hier, das ist der Max,
das ist unser Experte für Bereich XY und dann kannst du ein bisschen was zu erklären oder
bist einfach nur dabei, dass du paar Rückfragen beantworten kannst. Das macht, denke ich, einen
viel besseren Eindruck, als wenn deine Teamleiterin da sitzt, irgendwas zusammenstottert, was die
andere nicht verstehen und im Endeffekt dann Entscheidungen getroffen werden, auf der Basis
von etwas, was keiner der dort Beteiligten verstanden hat. Natürlich muss dann die
Teamleiterin auch erst mal erkennen, dass ihre Stärke nicht das technische Know-how ist, was aber
wiederum auch kein Problem ist, weil dafür ist sie eigentlich auch gar nicht da. Es ist
schwierig, ja, es kommt immer ein bisschen darauf an, wie die Leute so drauf sind. Egal, wir müssen jetzt
echt das Video weitergucken, ich habe schon wieder komplett vergessen, um was es geht. Also Gen Z
will nicht arbeiten. Das letzte war irgendein Boomer, der gesagt hat, die sind aber blöd oder so
was. ... die bei älteren Generationen oft auf Unverständnis stößt. Meine Wahrnehmung von dem
Ganzen ist, dass die jüngeren Mitarbeiter im Grunde genommen ziemlich schwer zu motivieren sind,
überhaupt Arbeit und mehr Leistung zu bringen. Das war der Aufhänger dafür, warum ich eben so lang
geschwätzt habe. ... fliegt am Arbeitsmarkt, während viele Boomer geprägt sind von arbeiten, arbeiten,
wir müssen was schaffen. ... will es die Generation Z ganz anders machen. Nicht so viel krassen
Leistungsdruck, sondern mehr auf die Menschen eingehen. Alexandra Thule ist ... Menschen,
Menschen, Alter, hör mal auf, was ist denn mit denen los? ... stellvertretende Chefredakteurin
vom Biber Magazin. Für mich als Millennial war es so ganz klassisch, dieses Danke, dass ich ...
Wait a minute, war Leonie24 nicht die andere? Das ist der falsche Text, oder? Das ist nicht
Leonie24. ... vom Biber Magazin. Für mich als Millennial ... Das ist Alexandra,
das ist nicht Leonie. ... stellvertretende Chefredakteurin vom Biber Magazin. Für mich
als Millennial war es so ganz klassisch, dieses Danke, dass ich hier überhaupt sein darf,
weil ich auch nicht mit dem aufgewachsen bin. Wollte ich gerade sagen, die sieht doch ein
bisschen älter aus als 24 und das ist nicht Leonie. ... dass man überhaupt Ansprüche
stellen kann. Anfang des Jahres schreibt sie ... Jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört,
was hat sie gesagt? Für mich als Millennial war es so ganz klassisch, dieses Danke,
dass ich hier überhaupt sein darf, weil ich auch nicht mit dem aufgewachsen bin,
dass man überhaupt Ansprüche stellen kann. What? Okay, die ist ungefähr mein Alter. Das
sieht man, das ist im Prinzip das, was ich gesagt habe. Meine Generation ist extrem gesplittert,
was das angeht. Du hast welche, die sind boomerigste Boomer und welche,
die reden mit 38 in Twitch-Emotes. Anfang des Jahres schreibt sie einen Kommentar,
in dem sie die Arbeitsmoral der Gen Z kritisiert. Liebe Generation Z,
wir müssen über eure Arbeitsmoral sprechen. Was kritisierst du daran genau? Dass ich am
Anfang eines Praktikums jetzt herkomme und sage, na, ich muss da jetzt gehen,
weil ich habe dann noch Yoga oder nein, ich mag das nicht machen, weil irgendwie taugt mir das
Thema jetzt nicht so, mache ich nicht. Das sind so Dinge, wo die Gen Z das so selbstverständlich
sieht. Die zahlreichen Reaktionen darauf zeigen. Wenn es nach Feierabend ist,
ist das auch selbstverständlich. Also ich sage nicht, dass es immer so sein muss,
aber wenn gerade ein Praktikant, alter, der nun wirklich schon eigentlich nichts dafür kriegt
und im Endeffekt eh so an der untersten Stelle der Nahrungskette steht und wahrscheinlich von
dem Praktikum am Ende auch noch nicht mal großartig was hat. Naja, also wenn der seine
Zeit dort war und kurz vor Feierabend der Chef um die Ecke kommt und es ist ein Praktikant,
weiß nicht, keine Ahnung. Ja, ich gebe zu, es ist nicht immer schlau zu sagen, mache ich nicht.
Weil es muss eine gewisse Balance geben zwischen dem, was man selbst will und das,
was man so von seinem Arbeitgeber erwartet. Wenn ich nie was mache quasi, wenn ich nie
irgendwie mal auch ein bisschen Einsatz zeige, dann kann ich auch nicht erwarten,
dass mein Arbeitgeber mal mir entgegenkommt in Sachen, die er auch nicht unbedingt machen
müsste. Nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel Urlaubsplanung jetzt. So, wenn ich jetzt jemand bin, der immer
super korrekt mit allem ist, so nach dem Motto, ja, ich habe jetzt da eigentlich schon was
eingetragen, aber es ist zufälligerweise, keine Ahnung, es geht zwei Tage vorher Totalausfall
und ich sage, oh ne, ich mache jetzt erstmal Urlaub und versus ich würde sagen, okay,
ich fahre eigentlich erst zwei Tage später weg, ich helfe euch jetzt noch zwei Tage das zu fixen,
aber dann muss ich wirklich weg, weil ansonsten verliere ich 3.000 Euro, weil ich Urlaub reise,
sonst wie schon bezahlt habe, kann dem Arbeitgeber in gewisser Weise entgegenkommen und sagen,
okay, ich helfe euch jetzt noch zwei Tage das mit zu fixen, aber mehr geht halt nicht und
dementsprechend kann ich dann aber auch, denke ich, erwarten, dass man bei der nächsten
Urlaubsplanung sagt, okay, ich weiß es jetzt noch nicht genau, wie das im Sommer ist,
könnt ihr mir da nochmal einen Monat mehr Zeit geben zum Einreichen der Planung. So,
das sind so zwei Sachen, würde ich beide Richtungen erwarten, da ich sage, okay,
ich komme meinem Arbeitgeber ein bisschen mehr entgegen über das, was ich eigentlich machen
müsste, umgedreht allerdings die auch und dann ist das auch okay und ich denke, so sollte das auch sein.
Dass man jetzt allerdings wie ganz selbstverständlich erwartet, dass einer über
seine Arbeitszeit hinaus dann arbeitet, nur weil es dem Chef fünf Minuten vor Schluss eingefallen
ist, ja, da kann man nicht drüber streiten, man kennt jetzt das Verhältnis zwischen dem Mitarbeiter
nicht, aber ich kann ihren Punkt auch durchaus nachvollziehen, ja. Wir hatten auch schon
Praktikanten, die sind angerückt und haben gesagt, so nach dem Motto, Alter, ich sitze hier eh nur rum
und eigentlich kann ich das schon alles, ich bin ja quasi schon, ja, oder Azubis, die haben angefangen,
so, ich habe da schon den kompletten Durchblick und kann alles und eigentlich sitze ich nur noch
hier, das waren mir eh die Liebsten dann immer. Egal, war fertig, gut.
Wo die Gin-Z das so selbstverständlich sieht.
Die zahlreichen Reaktionen darauf zeigen, das Thema polarisiert.
Unglaublich viel ist da abgegangen auf Twitter, auf Instagram. Egal, was ich für sonst Reportagen
mache zu wirklich wichtigen Themen, darauf kriege ich nicht so eine große Response und auf diesen
Kommentaren war die Response riesig, es waren zwei Lager, also es gab entweder die, die gesagt haben,
was ist das für ein Blödsinn, oh mein Gott.
Millennials sind die neuen Boomer. Ist doch gut, wenn junge Menschen in schlecht bezahlten
Positionen kein Blatt vor den Munde nehmen. Ich gehöre auch dazu.
Der Arbeitsmoral.
Ausgebrannt und mental am Ende mit Anfang 20. Danke für nichts.
Und dann aber auf der anderen Seite gab es Leute, die dann gesagt haben, wow, danke für diesen Text.
Ich finde auch ein bisschen mehr Respekt und Strenge.
Das ist im Internet ja normal, ja. Es gibt Leute, die stimmen der Sache zu, die erzählen,
die dann, okay, also es gibt so ein paar Sachen. Immer, wenn im Internet, also wenn im Internet
einer was postet, was der Meinung oder der Weltanschauung eines anderen entspricht,
da gibt es so Standardantworten, wo ich immer richtig cringen muss, ja.
Richtig und wichtig ist dann so ein Ding, was dann immer kommt.
Richtig und wichtig, dass das mal gesagt wurde. Oder was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Meine Höchstachtung und Respekt, dass das mal einer ausspricht oder sowas,
kommt dann immer als Antwort. Okay, da weißt du immer, okay, da sind Leute,
die haben im Prinzip eh schon die ganze Zeit das gedacht, was der geschrieben hat
und feiern sich jetzt darauf ab, ja. Meine Höchstachtung ist auch immer,
das ist so ein, wenn ihr den richtig, den Boomer-Poster oder den, tja,
weiß nicht, ob ich es jetzt sagen soll, aber es gibt so ein paar Leute,
da endlich sagt es jemand mal, das ist auch sowas.
Also, ich sage jetzt nicht nur, aber das sind so Dinge, die liest man immer so aus,
aus ähnlichen Ecken, ja. So dieses, ja, endlich sagt es mal jemand,
das ist richtig und wichtig, danke für den Mut, das endlich mal auszusprechen.
Das liest man entweder von Leuten, die eh schon so ein bisschen extreme Ansichten haben
oder ein bisschen aus so Verschwörungstheorie-Richtung, so nach dem Motto,
ja, mein gesunder Menschenverstand hat mir das schon immer so gesagt,
sehr wichtiger Beitrag, endlich sagt es mal jemand, so in der Richtung, ja.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Aluhut-Lager, ja.
Liest man, liest man das dann auch immer drauf, solche Antworten.
Und ja, das ist im Internet halt so, du hast einmal die, die halt dann total überschwänglich zustimmen
und dann dauert es meistens nicht lange, dann schlägt es entgegengesetzte Lager auf
zu dieser Meinung und leider ist es halt auf, im Internet so, dass es kaum jemand gibt,
der noch in der Lage ist zu sagen, okay, ich kann einen Punkt vielleicht aus deiner Sicht nachvollziehen,
aber ich sehe das komplett anders aus diesen und diesen Gründen,
sondern es gibt nur richtig und wichtiger Beitrag, endlich sagt es mal jemand,
meine Hochachtung, Hut ab dafür, dies auszusprechen.
Oder es gibt so, alter, ich rufe morgen bei deinem Arbeitgeber an,
dass du gefeuert wirst, du Kackspast, so.
Es gibt irgendwie, gefühlt, auf Social Media genau diese zwei Lager, ja.
Und das ist halt auch schon echt Pepega, gerade auf Twitter.
So, weiter.
... die dann gesagt haben, wow, danke für diesen Text.
Ich finde auch, ein bisschen mehr Respekt und strenge sich selbst gegenüber würde dieser Generation nicht schaden.
AnnaMiller86, gut, ungefähr genauso alt wie ich.
Ehrlich gesagt, das müssen die Leute doch alles selbst lernen.
Die Leute müssen selbst drauf kommen.
Ich habe es auch nie, also viele Sachen habe ich auch immer gesagt, alter, das ist Boomer-Geschwätz.
Ja, so warte mal ab, wenn du älter wirst, dann fallen dir manche Sachen nicht mehr so leicht und so.
Da habe ich früher immer gesagt, ja, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Und ich glaube zu dem Punkt, dass es sich durchaus lohnen kann,
in manchen Situationen Einsatz zu zeigen oder sich anzustrengen.
Das müssen Leute einfach selbst lernen.
Guck mal, wenn dir irgendwelche Telegram-Leute erzählen,
oh, musst du krass abhasseln und was und nicht alles machen musst,
das geht doch, realistisch betrachtet, den meisten Leuten ins eine Ohr rein, ins andere raus, glücklicherweise.
Ja, und wenn die Eltern erzählen so nach dem Motto, du musst jetzt mal ein bisschen Leistung bringen,
an der Stelle kannst du ja nicht immer nur den ganzen Tag rumchillen und so.
Das wird doch so nichts. Das geht ins eine Ohr rein, das geht ins andere Ohr raus.
Aber ich glaube, es muss einfach jeder selbst merken, dass es durchaus sich auszahlt,
dass es durchaus Vorteile für jemand hat oder für einen persönlich hat,
wenn man sich bei manchen Sachen auch mal ein bisschen anstrengt.
Aber das müssen die Leute selber einfach merken mit der Zeit.
Und die Menge und Intensität, wie sehr man sich anstrengen will,
das muss dann im Endeffekt auch jeder selbst für ihn bestimmen,
weil letztendlich ist es sein Leben, der kann machen, was er will.
Was ich dann halt ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, ist Leute, die permanent abchillen
und sich dann beschweren, dass es ihnen nicht gut geht.
So nach dem Motto, Alter, ich harze seit 15 Jahren und chill mein Leben
und ich kann mir keinen neuen BMW kaufen.
Ja gut, der Staat muss das bezahlen.
Wie kann das sein, dass ich keinen neuen BMW kaufe?
Ja gut, dem kann man dann auch nicht helfen.
Aber das ist ja das eine Extrem und das andere Extrem.
Deswegen, die Leute müssen es früher oder später selbst merken,
dass es sich lohnt, ein bisschen Eigeninitiative zu zeigen.
Und nur weil Anna Miller, 86, in ihrem Leben festgestellt hat,
oder für sich festgestellt hat, wie das sein muss,
heisst nicht zwangsläufig, dass es für jeden anderen auch so sein muss.
Junge Leute werden immer als respektlos eingestuft.
Auch wenn es Sokrates nicht wirklich gesagt hat, aber man dichtet ihm das ja an.
Das hat ja angeblich sogar Sokrates schon gesagt.
Und wenn die Griechen das schon erzählt haben,
scheint das doch ein weit verbreitetes Phänomen zu sein,
dass die älteren Leute immer denken, die Jungen sind super krass, respektlos und sonst was.
Und ja, sind sie wahrscheinlich auch, aber waren sie selber auch.
Kommen und einfach respektlos sind und einfach so sagen wie,
ja, du weißt eh nix, ich kenn mich da jetzt besser aus.
Wenn mir jemand von Anfang an schon daherkommt mit diesem,
du bist eh alt, du hast eh keine Ahnung, was willst du dann noch?
Glaubst du, dass sich die Teaching-Set auch ein bisschen zu wichtig nimmt?
Ich glaube schon, jetzt fühle ich mich wirklich sehr alt, wenn ich das sage,
aber auch so dieses Internet-mäßige, Instagram-mäßige,
jeder ist relevant, jeder muss zu jedem Thema was sagen,
meine Meinung zu jedem Thema ist wichtig.
Selbstbewusstsein.
Naja, ja, ja, ja, ja, stimmt schon.
Aber ich wette mit dir, sie denkt auch, dass ihre Meinung relevant und wichtig ist.
Also insofern, ich würde mich wundern, wenn das nicht jeder von sich denkt,
dass die eigene Meinung relevant und wichtig ist.
Also ich meine, die eigene Meinung ist ja auch relevant und wichtig,
zumindest für einen selbst, ja.
Ob das natürlich, wie das heute teilweise auf Twitter diskutiert wird,
jeder Hirnfurz, den irgendjemand hatte,
rausposaunt werden muss, so als würde es jetzt die Welt verändern,
ja, da kann man sich sicherlich drüber streiten.
Und ob man sich jetzt über Nebensätze, die Leute in irgendeinem Interview gesagt haben,
die überhaupt nicht Teil der Kernaussage waren,
auf Twitter drei Wochen circlejerken muss über irgendeine blöde Bemerkung in einem Nebensatz,
das finde ich auch übertrieben, ja, was da in der heutigen Zeit abgeht.
...Mut, Bewusstsein für Themen wie Klima und Mental Health.
Wir können laut Alexandra einiges von der GenZet lernen, aber dennoch...
Alter, was ist mit der Armlehne los? Seht ihr das?
Dass ich komplett rip die Armlehne, guck mal.
...Fragt sie sich...
Oder als moderne Kunst...
Wir haben auch Deadlines und da frage ich mich schon, wie das eigentlich dann in Zukunft ausschauen soll.
Ganz einfach realistische Deadlines machen.
Und nicht so nach dem Motto, wir sind in einer Woche fertig, wenn jetzt alle super krass crunchen 24-7.
Da macht man halt gescheite Deadlines und da braucht man halt auch mal gescheite Manager,
die ihren Jobtitel verdienen.
...Frage ich mich schon, wie das eigentlich dann in Zukunft ausschauen soll.
Und halt nicht einfach Agentur-Bullshit labern den ganzen Tag.
...Soll.
Um das herauszufinden, besuche ich die Lange Nacht der Bewerbung in Wien.
...auf Unternehmen. Ich will mich weiter umhören.
Wie will die Generation Z arbeiten?
Von meinem zukünftigen Arbeitgeber würde ich mir auf jeden Fall Respekt erwarten.
Auch, dass er mich als so einen Gleichgestellten quasi sieht.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten wären mir wichtig.
Also ich glaube, ich bin nicht gemacht für diese 9-to-5-Jobs.
Ich kann Ihnen schon mal sagen, ich glaube, gemacht ist da keiner für.
Von Montag bis Freitag.
...aber halt immer noch genügend Freizeit haben, um halt andere Sachen zu machen.
Tschädtke! Tschädtke!
Auch lustig, dass die Armlehne gewichtiger ist als der Inhalt.
Seriously, ich habe mich jetzt seit fast einer Stunde mit dem Inhalt beschäftigt, ja?
Und habe zwei Sätze über die Armlehne gesagt.
Oh nein!
Ganz schlimm.
Ich würde sagen, Work-Life-Balance.
Da versteht der Pontrec keinen Spaß bei sowas.
Vielleicht hat er es auch gar nicht so gemeint.
Anteimer unter ihm, aber wir sollten ihm da schon noch mal eine Chance geben.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass ich das auch falsch verstanden habe.
Okay, jetzt wird Zeug sortiert.
Okay, was wird sortiert?
Sicherheit, Gehalt, Sinn im Job.
Okay, Selbstverwirklichung.
...beschaulichen, wo die Prioritäten liegen, sollen Begriffe sortiert werden.
Ich würde sagen, Work-Life-Balance, weil ich mag meine Freizeit.
Und dann Gehalt, weil ich mag auch Geld.
Ja, gut, hey!
Tatsächlich, ja?
Seriously, ich glaube, ich würde das wahrscheinlich genauso raten wie die.
Work-Life-Balance und Geld.
Sicherheit.
Ähm...
Okay, soll ich auch mal raten?
Soll ich auch mal raten?
Okay, was haben wir denn?
Was haben wir denn? Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wir haben Work-Life-Balance, wir haben Gehalt, wir haben Sinn im Job, was auch immer.
Sicherheit, Flexibilität und Selbstverwirklichung.
Okay, Work-Life-Balance ist bei mir das Erste.
Das liegt bei mir schon daran, dass der Job nicht mein einziger Job ist,
sondern dass ich noch YouTube und Twitch mache.
Auch noch mich mit Dingern beschäftigen will, auf die ich Bock habe.
Was oftmals irgendwie schon mit meinem Job zusammenhängt.
Wenn ich mir irgendwelche neuen Programmiersprachen, Frameworks, sonst was angucke,
früher oder später bringt einem das immer mal was, auch im Job.
Aber da lege ich Wert drauf, ja?
Also, dass ich halt genug Zeit habe, um noch YouTube zu machen, Twitch zu machen.
Und halt auch noch Sachen, auf die ich Bock habe.
Also ich würde sagen, erstens ist bei mir auch ganz gleich Work-Life-Balance.
Das zweite ist bei mir auch Gehalt.
Letztendlich, ich gehe arbeiten, dass ich Geld verdiene.
Keine Frage.
Sinn im Job.
Ob mein Job Sinn macht, ist mir scheißegal.
Also sprich, ob da irgendwie ein Mehrwert für die Menschheit rauskommt, ist mir wurscht, ja?
Also ob ich da jetzt irgendwas mache, wo ich sagen würde,
oh ja, das hat jetzt irgendwie unsere Gesellschaft oder sonst was voll vorangebracht.
Ist mir egal.
Ganz ehrlich, ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung,
oder ja, ich habe bei einer Bank gearbeitet, ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung.
Ob da der Außendienst jetzt bei uns irgendwelchen Omas 100 Sachen mehr verkaufen kann,
durch gute IT-Systeme oder nicht, ist mir wurscht, ja?
Sicherheit ist mir tatsächlich auch nicht so wichtig.
Flexibilität, ja, ist die Frage, was damit gemeint ist.
Also wenn damit gemeint ist, dass man auch mal nach Hamburg fahren muss, um was zu machen,
dann ist es relativ weit unten.
Ich würde sagen, das ist gar nicht mal so unwichtig.
Was ich damit meine ist, wie gesagt, es mag jetzt vielleicht merkwürdig anmuten,
wenn ich sage Sinn, wenn ich sowas, Sinn, ja, Homeoffice und sowas, dann ist das dritter Punkt.
Homeoffice, also hier Homeoffice und Kleidzeit und so weiter, ja.
Dann würde ich das tatsächlich auf den dritten Platz setzen.
Das ist mir auch sehr wichtig.
Das vierte ist tatsächlich Selbstverwirklichung, weil ich würde darunter sowas sehen wie,
dass ich daran beteiligt bin an Technologieauswahl und in der Umsetzung von neuen Projekten
und dass ich dort auch die Möglichkeit habe, meine Sicht an Dinge einzubringen
und auch Sachen so umzusetzen, wie ich sie für richtig und gut halte.
Das bringt mir auch Spaß an der Arbeit, ja.
Das ist für mich auch, was Motivation angeht, sehr wichtig,
dass die Dinger gebaut werden nach einem System, was ich gut finde, sagen wir mal so.
Und ihr wisst, dass ich teilweise merkwürdige Ansichten habe, wie was gut sein muss,
aber ich bin dann meistens recht überzeugt von, dass das ein guter Weg ist,
wenn ich mich dafür entschieden habe, was so zu bauen.
Und das finde ich gut, wenn ich da an Entscheidungen beteiligt bin.
Beißt sich das nicht mit Sinn im Job, würde ich eher sehen in der Richtung wie,
ja, leiste ich da was so für das große Ganze.
Zum Beispiel, Sinn im Job würde ich sagen, Altenpfleger, ja.
Da geht es um Leben und Tod.
Da haben wirklich viele andere Leute was von, wenn ich diesen Job mache.
Das würde ich sagen, das ist mir eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Ja, so irgendwie sowas Soziales oder so, vielleicht Sinn im Job.
Sicherheit ist mir tatsächlich gar nicht so wichtig.
Klingt jetzt vielleicht auch blöd.
Ich meine, ich habe bei meinen letzten Arbeitgebern Jahrzehnte gefühlt gearbeitet.
Ja, bei den letzten zehn Jahren, bei dem da vorne, bei dem jetzt habe ich auch nicht vor zu wechseln.
Aber trotzdem, es ist mir nicht so wichtig.
Also, wenn die jetzt sagen würden, morgen, ja.
Unrealistisch als Fuck, aber nur mal theoretisch, ja.
Würden die jetzt sagen, Max, in zwei Monaten wird die gesamte IT dicht gemacht.
Wir bezahlen dir eine Abfindung.
Mach, dass du rauskommst.
Dann würde ich sagen, okay.
Ich fände es zwar irgendwie kacke.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, easy, alles kein Problem.
Ich fände es kacke, ja.
Gerade, wenn man schon eine Weile da ist.
Wenn man Leute kennt, sich eingearbeitet hat.
In gewissen, ja auch Bezug zu den Projekten und Teams und Leuten hat, mit denen man arbeitet.
Ich fände es blöd, ja.
Ich fände es echt auch ein bisschen belastend.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, oh nein.
Ich verzichte auch komplett auf mein Gehalt für ein halbes Jahr, wenn es dann noch ein bisschen weiter geht.
Ne, also ja, ich fände es blöd.
Ich fände es blöd, aber ich weiß auch, dass man in der IT relativ easy was Neues findet, genau.
Also Sicherheit ist für mich nicht ganz so wichtig.
So, und Sinn im Job, ob ich da irgendwas für die Allgemeinheit tue, ist mir egal.
Es sind sechs Punkte, ne, ja.
Das ist mir hier so, also quasi für die Allgemeinheit, ja.
Das ist mir egal.
Also so würde ich das raten, ja.
Work-Life-Balance, Gehalt, Flexibilität sowas, ja auch mal Selbstverwirklichung, Sicherheit.
Ja, so würde ich es wahrscheinlich raten.
Falls das, also falls das, was ich mir denke, was hinter den Punkten steckt, auch wirklich hinter den Punkten steckt,
weil wir haben die Einführung hier nicht mitbekommen dazu.
Du siehst es komplett anders.
Weißt du, das ist ja das Schöne an der ganzen Sache, es kann ja jeder für sich sehen, wie er will.
Wenn wir jetzt auf Twitter wären, dann würdest du jetzt dafür geflamed und ich dafür geflamed.
Aber ich finde, das sollte man jedem zugestehen.
Ich meine, es geht ja auch um seinen Job, um sein Leben, soll jeder so gewichten, wie er will.
Die ist 16, ja, die sieht es halt nochmal anders, ist doch okay.
Es kann doch jeder sehen, wie er will.
Und das klingt doch allen so, dass ihr die Welt mit 16 ein bisschen anders gesehen habt als mit 40.
Und ich wette mit euch, und das wird auch anders, ich wette mit euch auch,
dass viele Leute, die sich jetzt an der AUSU-Bahn festkleben,
das mit 40 vielleicht noch ein bisschen anders sehen werden.
Das ist immer, immer im Wandel.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten verändern ihre Ansichten, oder sagen wir mal so,
doch, vielleicht verändern viele ihre Ansichten nicht,
aber die Welt drumherum verändert sich.
Oder sagen wir mal so, die Ansichten der Leute verändern sich vielleicht langsamer als die Welt drumherum.
Aber so diese Interaktion zwischen den Leuten und der Welt drumherum,
das bleibt halt nicht einfach 80 Jahre gleich.
Also selbstverständlich hat man da andere Eindrücke mit 16 als mit 40.
Und das muss auch irgendwie so sein.
Das gehört halt irgendwie dazu.
Das hat jeder.
Und es ist auch normal, dass die Älteren sagen so,
du weißt noch gar nicht, was auf dich zukommt.
Und die Jungen sagen, Alter, eure Boomer-Ansichten sind total outdated.
Und mit 40 haben sie die gleichen Boomer-Ansichten gegen 16-Jährige dann, wenn sie 40 sind.
Also das ändert sich alles.
Ich denke, da muss man unterscheiden können.
Also, ich finde es gut, dass die Leute das machen.
Ach nee, das muss ich...
Wir kleben uns jetzt nochmal an die Straße.
Ich finde gut, dass Leute den Antrieb haben,
für ihre Überzeugung sowas zu machen.
Letztens habe ich gelesen, es hat sich einer in der Autobahn,
das ist kein Spaß, es hat sich einer von der Last Generation einbetoniert,
bei einer Autobahn-Auffahrt.
Da dachte ich mir auch, weißt du was, wäre nicht das Beste gewesen,
ich meine, es ist gerade 32 Grad draußen,
hätte man das nicht mal 8 Stunden sperren können
und den einfach 8 Stunden einbetoniert da stehen lassen oder so?
Also, ich finde es gut,
oder ich muss das anders formulieren,
weil ich finde, es sind zwei verschiedene Paar Schuhe.
Ich finde gut, dass Leute von irgendwas überzeugt sind
und versuchen, das der Welt mitzuteilen, nennen wir es mal so.
Über die Art und Weise kann man sich sicherlich streiten,
aber das finde ich prinzipiell gut.
Die Aktion an sich für mein Daily Business finde ich kacke.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock, dass meine Bahn oder mein Auto oder sonst was Verspätung hat.
Das ist ähnlich wie bei einem Bahnstreik.
Ich finde es voll und ganz in Ordnung, dass die streiken
und wahrscheinlich ist es auch gut, dass die mehr Geld bekommen.
Ich finde es trotzdem kacke, dass sie streiken, weil ich zu spät ankomme.
Deswegen finde ich es immer blöd, wenn dann erzählt wird auf Twitter,
Max, sei doch mal solidarisch mit den Bahnmitarbeitern.
Nein, muss ich nicht.
Ich kann aber den Unterschied machen zu,
ich verstehe, warum das alles gemacht wird,
aber für mich ist die Auswirkung scheiße.
Und so sehe ich das da auch.
Wenn ich im Stau stehe, weil sich irgendeiner festgepappt hat,
finde ich das kacke.
Ich finde nicht kacke, dass sie prinzipiell ihre Ansichten durchsetzen wollen.
Das nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist in vielen Bereichen so.
Es ist immer ein Unterschied zwischen Erklärung und Rechtfertigung.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das gescheit beschreiben kann.
Das ist so. Richtig.
Du hast voll und ganz recht.
Wenn die Leute es nicht scheiße finden würden,
zum Beispiel würde die Bahn nicht massig Geld verlieren
und würden es die Leute nicht scheiße finden,
wenn sie bei der Bahn streiken, hätten sie keinen Erfolg damit.
Das sehe ich genauso.
Ich kann das komplett nachvollziehen.
Aus dem Gesichtspunkt finde ich es gut, dass sie streiken.
Ich muss es aber nicht gut finden,
weil ich später auf die Arbeit komme oder im Stau stehe.
Es ist ein Unterschied zwischen, wie mich das persönlich betrifft
und wie ich solche Aktionen an sich finde.
Ich kann es durchaus nachvollziehen
und vom Ansatz her gut finden, dass sie bei der Bahn streiken.
Ich finde es aber für mich persönlich trotzdem scheiße,
dass sie streiken.
Es ist nicht immer so ganz schwarz und weiß.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich eigentlich sagen will.
Es ist nicht immer schwarz und weiß.
Das ist das, was mir auf vielen Social-Media-Diskussionen
auch ein bisschen verloren geht.
Entweder bist du dafür oder du bist dagegen.
Aber in Wirklichkeit ist das oft ein bisschen grau.
Und das wird oftmals nicht genug Rechnung getragen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich dazu draufgehe.
Wir haben das sortiert.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was sie sortiert.
Selbstverwirklichung könnte da sein.
Vielleicht Gehalt und Sicherheit.
Ich glaube, Gehalt ist schon wichtig.
Ich glaube, Sicherheit würde ich eher auf erster Stelle lassen,
weil ich mir denke, ich würde nicht jeden Tag zappeln müssen,
ob ich heute gekündigt werde.
Oder nicht.
30.
Ja, 30 Stunden ist okay.
Nicht schlecht.
38 Stunden oder so.
Aber dann freitags früher anzupacken.
38 Stunden.
Okay, die meint quasi 40 Stunden, dafür Freitag zwei.
Ja.
Das ist doch auch vollkommen okay.
Es ist eigentlich bescheuert, Glück nicht über Karriere zu stellen.
Für viele war vielleicht Glück gleich Karriere.
Das hängt sicherlich auch ein bisschen mit den eigenen Erwartungen an sich zusammen.
Aber es wäre doch blödsinnig zu sagen, man stellt Glück nicht über Karriere, oder?
Ich habe schon oft genug das Beispiel gebracht.
Wenn du Leute fragen könntest, kurz bevor sie sterben.
Du könntest quasi mit jedem ein Fünf-Minuten-Interview.
Du bist jetzt so halb Gott und kannst jetzt mit jedem kurz ein Interview führen,
fünf Minuten bevor er stirbt, so nach dem Motto.
Und wenn du die Leute dann fragst, was hättest du in deinem Leben anders machen wollen?
Die wenigsten werden sagen, Alter, mein Wunsch wäre echt noch,
in meinem Vertrieb auf den Mount Everest zu kommen.
Ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass ich noch das goldene Vertriebsabzeichen kriege.
Ich hätte mal mehr arbeiten sollen.
Das werden die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht sagen.
Die meisten werden dir erzählen, hätte ich mal ein bisschen früher angefangen,
mehr in Urlaub zu fliegen, hätte ich mal ein bisschen mehr mit meiner Familie gemacht,
hätte ich mich ein bisschen mehr um meine Kinder gekümmert.
Hätte ich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr damals in meiner Band gespielt.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Hätte ich mal mehr Sinnvolles gemacht für mich selbst oder für Leute, die mir wichtig sind.
Das werden dir die meisten sagen und nicht, hätte ich mal krass mehr gehasselt.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, er hat selbst ein Unternehmen gegründet.
Es mag auch immer andere Extremen geben.
So nach dem Motto, er hat jemand mal ein Unternehmen gegründet
und hat irgendwie eine richtige Fehlentscheidung getroffen,
die dann dazu geführt hat, dass es den Bach runtergegangen ist.
Dass er dann sagt, oh Mist, hätte ich mich damals anders entschieden, mag sein.
Warum steht dann Sinn bei dir ganz unten?
Weil es nicht um den Sinn meines Lebens geht oder den Sinn des Jobs.
Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche paar Sachen, die wir hier bewerten.
Hier haben wir geratet, wie sinnvoll ist der Job quasi oder wie wichtig ist der Job
für die Menschheit, für die Allgemeinheit, was man da macht.
Also sprich, sorgt man dafür, dass Leute nicht verbluten
oder sorgt man dafür, dass Leute besser Versicherungen verkaufen können?
Da würde ich sagen, ich sorge dafür, dass Leute besser Versicherungen verkaufen können.
Das ist jetzt sicherlich nicht wahnsinnig wichtig für die Allgemeinheit.
Das ist mir aber persönlich auch nicht wichtig,
dass ich was Wichtiges für die Allgemeinheit mache.
Ein Satz, den auch Leonie unterschreiben würde.
In ihrem alten Job war sie nämlich nicht glücklich.
Den Generationenkonflikt habe ich dort sehr stark gemerkt.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum die immer das Gleiche einblenden.
Die haben glaube ich nur diesen einen Einblender.
Den haben die wahrscheinlich von irgendeinem Pfeifer in der erstellen lassen
und der hat halt nur einen erstellt.
Und deswegen sind es jetzt alles, alle Leute, die hier auftreten in dem Video,
sind einfach Leonie24 Social Media Managerin.
In der Hoffnung, das merkt eh keiner.
Es war auf jeden Fall diese Kontrolle.
Homeoffice war gar keine Möglichkeit,
dass man auch irgendwie immer mehr arbeitet, als man eigentlich angestellt ist.
Und wenn du früher gegangen bist, war das ein absolutes No-Go.
Und dann hast du dir irgendwie drei Wochen später das noch anhören dürfen in der Küche.
Damals bist du aber sehr früh gegangen.
Alles sind so Dinge, die echt nicht mehr zeitgemäß sind, meiner Meinung nach.
Deswegen ist das Beste, was Leonie hätte machen können zu dem Zeitpunkt,
zu sagen, alter, fackt mich dieser Laden ab.
Ich such mir jetzt was Neues.
Und wenn sie was Neues hat, einfach zu sagen,
okay, Jungs, ich bin dann mal weg.
Oder was weiß ich, zwei Monate Kündigungsfrist,
14 Tage, drei Monate, weiß ich nicht, was sie hat.
Und tschüss.
Oh.
Kommt ja sogar jetzt.
Kack-Bye.
Heute ist es anders.
Seit nun knapp drei Jahren arbeitet Leonie hier bei Digitalwerk.
Ihre Arbeitszeiten sind flexibel.
Und vor kurzem hat sie sich bewusst dazu entschieden, auf Teilzeit zu reduzieren.
Ich arbeite aktuell 32 Stunden.
Ich habe freitags frei immer einen Tag.
Ich muss sagen, mir geht es sehr, sehr viel besser.
Freitag.
Ich finde, Montag ist die bessere Variante.
Aber muss jeder selbst wissen.
Ich kann euch auch sagen, warum ich finde, dass Montag die bessere Variante ist.
Und zwar, Montag sind alle noch super krass motiviert.
Das hat den Vorteil, wenn man selbst was machen möchte,
ist Montag ein guter Tag, das umzusetzen.
Montag auf der Arbeit ist immer stressig,
weil die Leute sind super motiviert.
Es sind vielleicht am Wochenende irgendwelche Sachen,
kleinere Sachen kaputt gegangen, die man sich angucken muss.
Also montags ist eigentlich immer richtig was los.
Und freitags ist eigentlich immer übelst gechillt.
Deswegen bin ich Montag.
Ich bin Montag.
Deswegen bin ich montags nicht auf der Arbeit.
Erstens spart man sich den Montag-Stress auf der Arbeit.
Und zweitens, wenn man selbst was erledigen will,
ist man meistens Montag selbst noch ein bisschen motivierter.
Und alle, mit denen man was machen will, sind auch noch motivierter.
Das heißt, Montag ist ein super Tag, wenn man selbst Sachen schaffen will.
Oder erledigen muss für sich.
Und das ist die beste Kombination.
Freitag übelst gechillter Tag und Montag super stressig.
Einfach montags nicht arbeiten. Beste Entscheidung.
Das fühlt sich echt super an.
Job kündigen, wenn dieser unglücklich macht.
Teilzeit arbeiten.
Eine Einstellung, die bei der älteren Generation Fragen aufwirft.
Bei allem Verständnis. Aber von was willst du deine Miete zahlen?
Von meinem Gehalt?
Die Gen Z muss auch Miete bezahlen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Das ist das Idealistische, das Romantisierte,
das noch unrealistisch Denkende.
Sie meint so nach dem Motto,
wenn die noch daheim wohnen,
dann müssen sie noch ...
Mag sein, dann werden sie das aber feststellen,
wenn sie ausziehen.
Alternativ ist einfach nicht für ein Apfel und ein Ei arbeiten gehen,
sondern sich einen gescheiten Job suchen.
Ich denke, dass das in der heutigen Zeit dank Fachkräftemangel
ganz gut funktioniert.
Zum Thema Fachkräftemangel.
Ich denke nicht, dass es einen Fachkräftemangel in der ...
Also der Definition nach vom Arbeitsamt gibt es einen Fachkräftemangel.
Nach meiner Definition nach gibt es
zwar auch einen, aber keinen allzu großen,
so wie es dargestellt wird.
Die Definition vom Arbeitsamt, was Fachkräftemangel ist,
bedeutet, diese Stelle ist so und so lange offen und unbesetzt,
und das wird gezählt,
und so und so viele Leute fehlen uns, also Fachkräftemangel.
Sprich, solange Stellen offen bleiben, Fachkräftemangel.
Was da nicht reingeht, ist,
die Stelle ist total unattraktiv, die will ja keiner machen,
deswegen bewirbt sich da keiner drauf.
Für das Arbeitsamt ist das Fachkräftemangel,
sobald die Stelle unbesetzt bleibt, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Dass nicht alle,
wenn man mal von irgendwelchen IT-Jobs ausgeht,
dass nicht jeder Arbeitgeber in der IT
sofort exakt den Kandidaten findet,
den er haben will.
Da würde ich mitgehen und sagen, wenn das schon Fachkräftemangel ist,
dann haben wir Fachkräftemangel.
Aber die meisten Unternehmen, wenn sie sich etwas Mühe geben würden,
denke ich, dass sie Leute finden würden.
Das heißt aber auch,
danke für den Sub und danke auch an,
ich glaube, ich habe etwas übersehen.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Übrigens, wenn ihr Prime-Subs übrig habt,
ich freue mich immer drüber, aber ihr müsst die nicht mir geben,
gebt die nur irgendjemand auf Twitch,
weil sonst ist ja quasi direkte Überweisung an Besos,
und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wollt.
Wenn es Fachkräftemangel ist, dann okay,
aber ich denke, die meisten würden jemand bekommen,
wenn sie an einem der drei Stellschrauben drehen,
die es denn da gibt, Leute zu bekommen.
Die erste ist, man muss sein eigenes Unternehmen attraktiver machen.
Da gibt es zig Varianten.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit, wo ich jetzt arbeite,
die haben sogar einen Kindergarten, Kinderbetreuung.
Das ist natürlich für Eltern oder angehende Eltern ein Riesending.
Das kann sich selbstverständlich nicht jeder leisten.
Klassik, 420, danke für den Sub.
Nur mal so als Beispiel.
Also man muss den eigenen Laden attraktiver machen.
Und das kann oftmals nach außen hin für Bewerbung attraktiver machen.
Das kann durchaus sein,
dass der eigene Laden oder das Unternehmen,
was Leute sucht, sogar schon attraktiv ist,
aber das einfach nur nicht richtig kommuniziert.
Es gibt ja schon viele Betriebssystemauswahl,
Kantine im Haus,
Firmenhandys, die man privat benutzen darf, was auch immer.
Es gibt ja schon durchaus Pluspunkte,
die man einfach mal erwähnen kann, wenn es die gibt
und die auch sehrlich bei dem einen oder anderen gut ankommen.
Also man muss irgendwie gucken,
dass man sein eigenes Unternehmen attraktiv dastehen lässt.
Da scheitern ja schon ganz viele Betriebe dran, die Bewerber suchen.
Es gibt ja schon viele, die sagen,
das ist so extrem langweilig, 0815.
Wir sind in der Technologie führend,
Blablabla, Marktführer im Bereich XY.
Wir suchen neue motivierte Mitarbeiter
für unser Administrationsteam,
für unser Entwicklerteam und Blablabla.
Es ist so langweilig.
Es ist immer der gleiche Kram.
Lässiger Lord, dankeschön für den lässigen Sub.
Es ist so langweilig
und sticht überhaupt nicht raus
und gibt auch überhaupt keinen Anlass,
warum sich da jemand jetzt dazu
irgendwie hingezogen fühlen sollte,
sich da zu bewerben.
Da sind die Unternehmen teilweise schon echt selbst dran schuld,
dass sie da so 0815 Bewerbungen machen.
Die Unternehmen könnten es deutlich besser machen,
wenn sie ordentliche Stellanzeigen schreiben würden
und sich da mal wirklich Gedanken drüber machen würden
und auch mal in sich gehen, was ist denn bei uns wirklich gut.
Sie könnten wirklich viel bessere Stellanzeigen schreiben,
machen sie aber nicht.
Das ist schon mal das Erste, die Einstiegshürde gefunden zu werden.
Das Nächste, was sie machen können,
ist, sie können ihre Ansprüche runterschrauben.
Das können selbstverständlich Unternehmen auch machen,
wenn sie sagen, wir finden niemanden,
der 15 Jahre Kubanetas Erfahrung hat.
Es reicht vielleicht auch, wenn wir jemanden haben,
der nur 2 Jahre Erfahrung hat,
aber wo wir den Eindruck haben,
der interessiert sich sehr dafür und den arbeiten wir dann ein.
Das war jetzt ein Witz, mit 15 Jahren Kubanetas
gibt es den Kram ja noch gar nicht.
Weil gerade in der IT ist es nun mal so,
der Skill, sich einarbeiten zu können,
beziehungsweise zu googeln,
ist eigentlich das Wichtigste schlechthin.
Und wenn du einen hast, der motiviert ist und das kann,
der kann sich relativ schnell, gerade mit Unterstützung von Leuten,
die Ahnung in dem Thema haben, relativ schnell einarbeiten.
Guck mal, du kannst mich heute auch vor irgendeine Kiste setzen
und von der ich keine Ahnung habe, ich gucke mir das ein bisschen,
ich kann das nach einer Weile, nach ein paar Tagen,
je nachdem wie kompliziert das ist, nach ein paar Wochen,
ich kriege das hin, das ist eigentlich meistens kein Ding.
Solange ich will. Es gibt Sachen, die will ich nicht,
z.B. Windows administrieren, das mache ich auch nicht.
Und der dritte Punkt, was Unternehmen machen können,
wenn sie keine Leute bekommen,
ist, sie können einfach bessere Gehälter bieten
und dementsprechend offensiv auch das reinschreiben.
Nicht nur diese Sache mit ein angemessenes
oder ein leistungsorientiertes Gehalt,
ein marktübliches Gehalt, bla bla bla,
diese Formulierung will doch keine Sau lesen.
Wenn da drin steht, das ist eine, keine Ahnung,
eine Einsteiger-Junior-Entwickler-Stelle,
wir bezahlen die aber 65.000 im Jahr,
dann sagen die, ja, das gucke ich mir doch mal an.
Ist mir eigentlich egal, dass die Stellenanzeige
sich ziemlich 0815 liest, aber die bezahlen mir
zum Einstieg 65.000, das bezahlt sonst keiner
und dann auf geht's, let's go.
Das kann man natürlich auch machen, die Variante gibt es.
Und nur weil Unternehmen da komplett drinne failen,
heißt es nicht zwangsläufig, dass sie nicht Leute
bekommen könnten, würden sie sich ein bisschen Mühe geben.
Klar, insgesamt gibt es nicht genug Leute,
das würde ich auch so unterschreiben.
Ich habe vor nicht allzu langer Zeit ein Video geguckt,
da hat ein Recruiting-Spezialist,
von den meisten dieser Leute halte ich nichts,
aber der hat wirklich was Sinnvolles gesagt,
und zwar hat er gesagt, hey, es ist heute so,
dass viele Leute in ihrem aktuellen Job
eigentlich nur noch Dienst nach Vorschrift machen
und noch in dem Job sind, weil es sich noch nicht genug abfuckt,
aber wirklich groß verbunden mit dem Job und dem Arbeitgeber
und die haben eigentlich gar keinen großen Bock da drauf,
die machen es weiter, weil sie zu faul sind
und sich was Neues suchen, dass der Leidensdruck
noch nicht hoch genug ist, aber wenn du die anschreibst
mit einem guten Angebot, dann sind die sehr wohl bereit,
sich das anzuhören und auch relativ zügig zu wechseln.
Und das kann ich gerade rückblickend,
wenn ich mir die Leute angucke, also mich selbst
und bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber auch,
die sagen mir, es ist okay, es nervt nicht,
es ist jetzt nicht super, es ist aber auch nicht super schlimm,
es ist auch ein gewisser Aufwand, sich mal aufzuraffen,
Bewerbungen zu schreiben, die sind einfach noch da,
sind innerlich nicht so wirklich da verbunden mit dem Arbeitgeber,
würden wechseln, aber haben keinen Bock,
sich selbst darum zu kümmern.
Wenn man denen mit einem guten Job am Angebot kommt,
dann sagen die relativ schnell, let's go,
die Sachen stimmen und der neue Arbeitgeber das bietet,
was den Leuten wichtig ist.
Aber ich muss das Video fertig gucken, ich kriege langsam übelst Hunger.
Wie die das später machen wollen?
Die Gen Z wird ihre Miete genauso bezahlen wie Gen Y und Gen X
mit dem, was sie so verdienen.
Vielleicht sagt allerdings Gen Z,
mir reicht auch eine kleinere Wohnung aus
oder ich kann dank Homeoffice beispielsweise
von woanders arbeiten, wo das Wohnen nicht so teuer ist.
Das Argument von ihr verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Wie die das später machen wollen?
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage,
wie kann sich die Gen Z leisten,
auch einfach nicht 40 Stunden zu arbeiten?
Ja, einfach die Ansprüche runterschrauben.
Du musst nicht fünfmal im Jahr im Urlaub fahren,
du brauchst kein Riesenhaus oder sonst was.
Aber wenn du nicht für jeden Scheiß Geld ausgibst,
geht das schon.
Was natürlich nicht geht ist,
neues Auto, Autotune, neues Smartphone, fette Wohnung oder sonst was.
Ja klar, dann ist die Kohle weg.
Dann kannst du das nicht machen.
Oder in einem ordentlichen Job arbeiten, wo es viel Geld gibt,
das ist natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit.
Das ist so ein Punkt, der wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwieriger ist.
Die Wohnungspreise gehen wahnsinnig in die Höhe.
Es wird nicht günstiger, es wird nur immer teurer.
Alle wollen einfach ein Haus erben.
Alleine wohnen.
Da clasht dieser Wunsch mit diesen äußeren Umständen zusammen,
weil es teilweise dann doch unleistbar ist.
Obwohl es noch schwierig scheint,
für alle den Wunsch mit der Realität zu vereinbaren,
hat Leonie einen Weg für sich gefunden.
Ja, es ist weniger Geld.
Ich kann dann vielleicht im Monat zweimal weniger essen gehen
oder dreimal weniger ausgehen.
Aber mir ist das einfach mehr wert, die Zeit, die ich dafür habe.
Klingt doch voll und ganz nachvollziehbar.
Und wenn die Kohle reicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie gut es bei den Influencer-Marketing-Leuten läuft.
Gerade in dem Bereich,
wenn du gut bist und einen gescheiten Arbeitgeber hast,
kannst du wirklich enorm viel Geld machen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich es erzählen darf.
Vielleicht kann ich mit ihm mal ein Video machen irgendwann.
Und er erzählt es selber.
Ich kenne ja schon seit Jahren ein paar,
die Online-Marketing machen.
Mit manchen hat man auch mehr Kontakt, mit manchen weniger.
Meine Meinung bleibt weiterhin bestehen.
Nee, kann ich nicht erzählen.
Aus meiner Sicht ist Online-Marketing
die einzige Kloake an Jobs.
Gerade Influencer-Kram.
Aber ich habe es letztens schon gesagt.
Was mich auch sehr gewundert hat,
weil ich es selbst nicht vermutet hätte.
Von allen Marketing-Agenturen und Social-Media-Management-Gedöns,
was ich in letzter Zeit gehört habe,
wo es wirklich ganz gut sein muss,
ist tatsächlich TikTok.
Ich mag es fast nicht glauben,
aber die China-Chinesen haben wohl eine echt gute Arbeitsatmosphäre
im Online-Marketing.
Zumindest in der EU-Niederlassung.
Ausgerechnet TikTok von denen,
wo man es am wenigsten erwarten würde.
Faul sein habe das aber nichts zu tun.
Man will es nur eben nicht so machen wie die Generationen davor.
Wir haben andere Prioritäten.
Auch das Leben zu genießen.
Also eben sowas wie Reisen, Persönlichkeitsentwicklung.
Der Dialekt von Österreicher macht mich immer fertig.
Reisen.
Also eben sowas wie Reisen, Persönlichkeitsentwicklung.
Dass wir nicht 40, 50 Jahre lang an etwas arbeiten,
was uns nicht Spaß macht.
Auch mit weniger Geld wir eher glücklich sein wollen,
als die Arbeit zu verrotten.
Oder sich eben zum Burnout zu stressen.
Ich verstehe gar nicht,
wie man das irgendwie groß kritisieren kann.
Man kann es alles kritisieren,
aber das klingt doch komplett logisch und nachvollziehbar.
Das ist im Prinzip das, was ich gesagt habe.
Wenn man mit ein bisschen weniger auskommt,
dann macht sein unter dem Strich glücklicher.
Auch mit weniger Arbeit.
Es ist doch gut.
Es muss doch nicht immer nur das neue Smartphone sein,
was einen happy macht.
Oder neuer Fernseher, neues Auto, neues Sonstwas.
Ich glaube, dass sich tatsächlich die Generationen davor
und auch danach, meine Generation und auch die vor mir,
schon ein bisschen ihr Glück darüber definiert hat,
wie krass sie sich was leisten können.
Für die war Glück, neuer Fernseher, neues Auto,
fünfmal in Urlaub und sowas in der Richtung.
Ob die mal in sich geguckt haben und ob das wirklich das ist,
was sie jetzt ultimativ glücklich gemacht hat,
sei mal dahingestellt.
Ich glaube, da sind die tatsächlich ein bisschen moderner im Kopf.
Die sind ja auch noch jünger.
Ich kann mich mehr mit dieser Sicht der Dinge identifizieren,
als mit der anderen.
Deswegen arbeite ich auch nur Teilzeit.
Wir sind halt die Generation der Zukunft.
Ich gebe kaum Geld aus und ich arbeite Teilzeit.
Was mache ich mit meinem Geld?
Ich kaufe mir ein bisschen Stonks.
Damit das nicht weniger wird.
Rufe nach neuen Arbeitsmodellen werden immer lauter.
Islands führt das weltweit größte Experiment zur 4-Tage-Woche durch.
Wer?
Island.
Teilnehmende haben über mehrere Jahre
ihre Wochenarbeitszeit von 40 auf 35 Stunden
bei gleichem Gehalt reduziert.
Die Resultate zeigen,
die Zufriedenheit, aber auch die Produktivität verbesserten sich.
Und Isländer sind doch eh schon die glücklichsten Menschen, oder?
Oder denen?
Bin?
Nee, Schweden nicht.
Ach, keiner.
Ja, okay.
Ich wollte irgendwas noch vergessen.
Was wollte ich denn?
Resultate zeigen,
die Zufriedenheit, aber auch die Produktivität verbesserten sich.
Ja, ach ja.
Also sollten die bei uns wirklich mal auf die Idee kommen, zu sagen,
35 oder gar 30 Stunden für gleiches Gehalt,
ich bin sofort dabei.
Schade, dass es bei uns keine Volksabstimmung gibt,
wie in der Schweiz zu sowas.
Ich wäre sofort dabei.
Weil, wisst ihr, was das für mich bedeuten würde?
Das würde bedeuten,
instant 20% mehr Geld.
Weil ich mache ja schon 4 Tage Woche.
Also insofern wäre ich sofort dabei.
Sobald sowas kommt,
also ohne Mist, sollte irgendeine Partei damit in den Wahlkampf gehen,
35 Stunden Woche, die wird gewählt.
Instant.
Das würde für mich nämlich einfach nur direkt Gehaltserhöhung bedeuten.
Ey, und selbst wenn es die AfD ist.
Wenn irgendjemand verspricht,
dann wird es garantiert,
wenn wir etwas zu sagen haben,
dann gibt es garantiert,
und das müsste in irgendeiner Form auch glaubhaft sein,
gibt es 30 Stunden.
Instant, ist mir alles andere egal.
Ich meine, wer würde Nein sagen,
zu 20% mehr Gehalt für das Gleiche, was er macht?
Das Dumme ist nur im Endeffekt,
die AfD ist wunderbar im Labern,
so nach dem Motto,
mit uns wird das alles besser,
die müssen ja aktuell hauptsächlich existieren,
und die anderen quasi Werbung für sich machen lassen,
also Negativwerbung für sich machen lassen.
Das heißt, das ist dann auch nicht sonderlich glaubwürdig.
Aber wenn es glaubwürdig wäre,
wenn es irgendeine Partei für mich glaubwürdig vertreten würde,
dass sie aus 40-Stunden-Woche 30-Stunden-Woche machen würden,
wenn sie gewählt werden, dann wähle ich die.
Ist mir egal, wer das ist.
20% mehr Kohle, easy, ist mir egal, juckt mich nicht.
Und selbst wenn es so scheiße werden sollte,
in dieser Regierungsperiode,
dann mache ich Homeoffice vom Ausland aus.
Ist mir egal, zu 20% mehr Geld,
sage ich nicht Nein.
Realistisch betrachtet ist das natürlich Blödsinn.
Weil wenn es uns hier so scheiße geht,
dass man nur noch mit Homeoffice arbeiten kann,
dann geht es auch anderweitig den Bach runter.
Wenn man das mal im Kern durchdenkt,
ergibt das natürlich keinen Sinn, das so zu machen.
Und es wird ja eh keiner wirklich glaubhaft
so bewerben können, dass sie es auch machen,
wenn sie das durchhalten.
Nach Dubai zu den ganzen Influencer-Dudes.
Boah, da würde ich im Leben nicht hingehen.
Das ist auch so ein Kackland, auf das ich keinen Bock hätte.
Ich muss ja sagen, es wird hier immer viel rumgehackt.
Aber ich lebe hier eigentlich ganz gerne.
Trotz, dass alles ja so angeblich furchtbar schlimm ist.
Zumindest wenn man sich das auf Social Media anguckt.
Gefühlt so schlimm wie noch nie.
Aber ich finde es hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Und wenn man es mal realistisch betrachtet,
hat sich auch die letzten Jahrzehnte sehr viel verbessert.
Es ist sicherlich nicht alles gut,
aber es hat sich sehr viel verbessert.
Also diese Weltuntergangsszenarien.
Dass man so tut, als hättest du heute immer noch so viele Probleme.
Du kannst dich heute persönlich so frei entfalten,
wie noch nie vorher.
Und da bin ich eigentlich ganz dankbar drum,
dass es hier so ist.
Wenn man mal in andere Länder guckt,
da hast du mehr Probleme.
Geh mal in den Nahen Osten oder nach Russland und sag, ich bin schwul.
Dann hast du andere Sorgen.
Hier würde es keinen interessieren.
Leute, wenn ich mich hier in den Stream stelle und sage,
Jungs, wisst ihr eigentlich, ich bin schwul.
Dann würde ich sagen, und weiter Max, wen juckt es?
Aber im Großen und Ganzen geht es den Leuten mega am Arsch vorbei.
Und das finde ich okay.
Das muss sie auch überhaupt nicht interessieren.
Das ist auch sowas, was mich social-media-technisch immer nervt.
So nach dem Motto, bist du nicht dafür, bist du dagegen.
Leute, den meisten Leuten geht es am Arsch vorbei,
ob ich schwul wäre oder nicht.
Und das ist okay. Das ist in Ordnung.
Die sollen mich in Ruhe lassen und ich lasse sie auch in Ruhe.
Insofern finde ich das, so wie es jetzt aktuell ist,
schon enorme Fortschritte.
Versus die letzten 50 Jahre reicht schon, die du dir angucken musst.
Klar, es ist sicherlich nicht alles toll.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du dich in Dresden an der falschen Stelle
als Schwarzer vor ein Einkaufszentrum stellst,
hast du wahrscheinlich so ein paar Probleme.
Je nachdem, in welcher Region, in welcher Gegend das so ist.
Es ist nicht alles gut.
Es gibt sicherlich noch viele Sachen, die man verbessern kann.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn man sich mal die Fortschritte anguckt,
die wir die letzten 50 Jahre gemacht haben,
es macht keinen Sinn, so krass rumzuheulen,
wie es auf Social Media passiert.
Gerade persönliche Entfaltung hat sich enorm verbessert.
Und ich finde es hier eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe keine Ambition, auszuwandern.
Ich denke, es sollen sie machen, wenn sie wollen.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit MMO gespielt.
Bei einem aus unserer Gruppe.
Wir haben da alle möglichen, jüngere, ältere Leute in der Gilde.
Wir haben zum Beispiel einen,
der ist ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen,
ein bisschen gegen viele der aktuellen Entwicklungen.
Der hat die ganze Zeit erzählt,
ich will jetzt auswandern, ich kann nicht mehr atmen hier.
Die Freiheit geht zugrunde.
Hast du halt auch so Leute,
das ist schon ein bisschen übertrieben alles.
Ich finde es hier insgesamt eigentlich ganz gut.
5 Minuten Delay war das.
10 Minuten Delay.
Ich kann aktuell kein MMO empfehlen.
Ich spiele gerade aktuell kein MMO.
Ich finde ehrlich gesagt,
dass beide Seiten sehr übertreiben.
So nach dem Motto,
hier ist alles ganz furchtbar schlimm und Unterdrückung und Rassismus.
An jeder Ecke ist hier ganz furchtbar wild.
Man muss sich permanent drüber auskotzen.
Dann hast du die andere Seite,
nach dem Motto, Impfzwang und hier,
ganz furchtbar schlimm und hier kann man nicht mehr atmen.
Ich finde es übertrieben, beide Seiten, einfach nur maßlos.
Insgesamt finde ich die Mischung hier bei uns ganz okay.
Es ist nicht nur die Medien, das sicherlich auch.
Es ist vor allem die Leute, die sich so krass reinsteigern überall.
Ich glaube, am besten kann man das damit zusammenfassen,
diese Mentalität, die es immer verbreiteter
und gerade auf Social Media gibt,
jeder, der nicht ganz klar für was ist,
ist automatisch dagegen und muss zerstört werden.
Das ist leider viel zu reingesteigert auch mittlerweile.
Reinsteigern trifft es dann wirklich ganz gut.
Man sieht es doch allein schon daran,
dass die Kronk, Alter,
das ist glaube ich so eines der,
ich meine, ich habe persönlich mit ihm was nie zu tun,
ich bin auch kein großer Kronk-Gucker,
aber ich glaube, das ist eigentlich so eines der
gebasesten, gibt es dieses Wort,
am gebasesten
Streamer und Let's-Player,
den es so gibt.
Dass die bei dem so Riesen-Attacke gemacht haben,
vor ein paar Monaten, allein schon das,
sieht man doch, dass die alle nicht mehr ganz dicht sind.
Natürlich, das passiert ja immer.
Das ist auch das,
in dem einen Livestream, wo ich ein Clip gesehen habe,
so drüber aufgeregt hat, macht er was?
Wird er angeschissen dafür, dass er es macht?
Macht er es nicht, wird er von den anderen Leuten angeschissen,
dass er eingebrochen ist und nachgegeben hat.
Der arme Kronk, Alter, an der Stelle.
Du kannst jetzt natürlich auch sagen, who cares Kronk,
der hat eh schon ausgesorgt, aber man hat gemerkt,
den nervt das richtig.
Unterm Strich hat er sogar noch mehr Zuschauer.
Diese ganze Diskussion um das Wizard-Game zum Beispiel,
hat ja im Endeffekt schlussendlich nur dafür gesorgt,
dass sich am Ende der Scheiß sogar noch mehr verkauft hat.
Es hat nichts gebracht, zu dieses ganze Ultra-Reingesteigere.
Und was halt prinzipiell nie was bringt,
ist, pauschal allen Leuten zu sagen, sie sind scheiße.
Unabhängig davon, ob es stimmt oder nicht.
Niemand hört gerne, dass er scheiße ist.
Oftmals noch nicht mal wissend, um was es eigentlich geht.
So nach dem Motto, du bist scheiße, um was geht es?
Egal, du bist scheiße.
Das hört halt keiner gerne.
Und der lässt sich dann von sowas auch nicht überzeugen.
Das muss da anders angehen.
Und Leute überzeugen ist eh unglaublich schwierig.
Weil viele sind nicht für Fakten empfänglich.
Für andere Meinungen auch nicht.
Viele Leute sind auch einfach nicht überzeugbar.
Damit muss man auch leben.
Und ihr wisst, wie sehr mich der Umgang mit anderen Menschen abfuckt.
Ist es rassistisch, wenn man alle nicht mag?
Nicht, oder? Ich mag alle Menschen nicht.
Was ich mag, sind Katzen z.B.
Ich würde beispielsweise,
ich kann mit meinem Geld machen, was ich will.
Aber ich würde lieber
an mein Tierheim spenden.
Hier lokal, wo ich weiß, was abgeht.
Und dass die es wirklich nicht einfach haben.
Und dass sie gerade nach Corona-Zeiten auch viele Probleme haben.
Mit eingelieferten Tieren.
Und sich kaum noch retten können.
Vor Kosten und Unterbringung.
Ich würde lieber,
ich habe ja auch schon nicht nur an mein Tierheim gespendet.
Sondern auch schon an andere Tierorganisationen gespendet.
Lieber dafür spenden, als sagen wir,
ans Rote Kreuz oder sowas.
Lieber Tiere, die nichts dafür können,
als an irgendwelche Menschenhilfsorganisationen.
Bestes Thema zum Subscriben.
Finanzamt kann zuschauen.
Weil ich mache meine Steuern mit dem Steuerbereiter immer ultra korrekt.
Und habe auch für sowas Belege.
Gut, man kann es auch ohne Belege machen.
Aber dann kriegt man halt kein Geld wieder.
Rundumschlag zu Social Media.
Ich kann jetzt nicht alles verraten.
In Wirklichkeit, erinnert ihr euch noch an das Containerschiff?
Das so ein bisschen schief stand?
Hat wahrscheinlich schon wieder jeder vergessen.
Leute, ich habe Hunger. Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt was essen.
Nee, nicht Concordia. Concordia war das Ding in Italien.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das Ding hieß.
Das Schiff war in diesem Kanal.
Evergreen hieß das?
Nee, Concordia war das Ding,
was vor der italienischen Küste auf Grund gelaufen ist.
Mit dem Captain,
der sich aus dem Staub gemacht hat.
Das war ja auch ein geiler Dude.
So nach dem Motto, oh Mist, ich bin Captain.
Mein Schiff geht unter.
Das Erste, was ich mache, ist, ich bringe mich mal in Sicherheit.
Dann ruft ihn die Seerettung oder sowas noch an.
Dann erzählt er denen irgendein Shit zu.
Das Video war richtig gut.
Wie hieß das?
Cost of Concordia hieß das.
Das war ein mega geiles Video. Richtig, richtig gut gemacht.
Zu einer eigentlich ziemlich tragischen Sache, muss man ja sagen.
Richtig gut gemacht, das Video.
Okay, Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich glaube, nachher
eventuell machen wir noch folgendes.
Nachher machen wir, glaube ich,
I use PHP, by the way.
Irgendwie ist mir es heute danach ein bisschen PHP zu machen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von PHP.
Also schon ewig her, wo ich zuletzt PHP benutzt habe.
Und wir werden
CAC W as a Service in PHP neu entwickeln.
Also wer sich fragt, was CAC W as a Service ist,
das ist nicht das.
Wo ist denn meins?
Gibt es das gar nicht mehr?
GitHub down, PostChamp.
Ne, Browser kaputt, PostChamp.
Also Repo, CAC W.
CAC W as a Service, genau.
Das werden wir neu bauen in PHP.
Das ist was ultra simples. Das ist eine Web-Anwendung.
Und rotiert sich random im Kreis.
Das ist alles. Wer macht das nicht?
Das ist mega.
Simpler kann das echt nicht sein.
Das ist die gesamte Logik.
Wir probieren das mal in PHP zu machen.
Was, glaube ich, ganz gut ist zum Einstieg in PHP,
weil ich keine Ahnung habe von PHP.
Wem followinge ich denn?
Besten deutschsprachiger Streamer,
der es nötig hat, mal gehostet zu werden.
Der Lost hat es nicht nötig.
Der hat 1,1k Zuschauer.
Ich habe Hunger, Leute. Ich gehe jetzt essen.
Ist das der von Semper Video?
Der ist gar nicht on.
Haben wir, glaube ich, das letzte Mal gehostet.
Ne, egal. Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Ich muss jetzt was essen. Bis dann.
See you.